24 Welt aus den Fugen mein Name ist
Sandra Tier und ich darf Sie heute
durchs Programm begleiten und wir haben
einiges vor wir erwarten hochkaretige
ExpertInnen die gemeinsam ja die für
Österreich relevanten Krisen und
kriegsregionen einordnen wollen wir
wollen zurückblicken auf das Jahr 2023
was ist wo genau passiert und wir wollen
aber auch vorausschauen wie geht's 2024
weiter außerdem wollen wir natürlich die
spannende Frage beleuchten was bedeutet
das für Europa und vor allem für
Österreich deshalb danke dass Sie so
zahlreich erschienen sind der Saal ist
wirklich voll das Thema pressiert würde
ich mal sagen ich darf sie wirklich all
sehr herzlich willkommen heißen auch die
vielen Journalisten die akkreditiert
sind und zu Beginn möchte ich jetzt die
Begrüßungsworte übergeben an Erwin
Hameseder der Generalanwalt des
österreichischen reifessenverbandes und
Generalmajor der Miliz schön dass Sie da
sind einen schönen guten Morgen bitte um
ihre
[Applaus]
Begrüßungsworte
hochgeschätzte Frau Bundesministerin
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
Exzellenzen hohe Generalität meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren ich darf sie
schon mittlerweile Frau Bundesminister
das darf ich wohl so sagen
traditionell zum sicherheitspolitischen
jahresauftagt in unserem Haus
begrüßen die Präsentation des
risikobildes liefert insbesondere auch
für die
sehr wertvolle ja unverzichtbare
Grundlagen für eigene Beurteilungen und
Analysen und zwar jener Gefahren und
Risiken mit denen wir gegenwärtig und
auch höchstwahrscheinlich zukünftig
konfrontiert sein
werden in der Wirtschaft da fragen wir
uns schon mittlerweile seit längerem
gibt es noch eine
richtungsweise richtungsweisende
sicherheitsordnung das ist etwas sehr
Wichtiges weil man nur auf bas ist einer
gewissen Richtungsweisung auch dann
Investitionsentscheidungen treffen kann
und vor kurzen fand im Rahmen des Tages
der whrpflicht eine sehr hochrangig
besetzte Veranstaltung an der Bund an
der Spitze Frau Bundesminister und unser
Herr Generalstabschef unter dem Titel
Ring of Fire Europas Herausforderungen
statt warum Ring of Fire nun der Ring
ist vereinfacht geographisch zu sehen
und bezieht sich insbesondere auf die
Krisenherde die wichtig die großen
Krisenherde die uns derzeit alle massiv
beschäftigen das beginnt mit einem
möglichen Konflikt China Taiwan das
Südchinesische Meer geht über den Iran
naost zu es Kanal und natürlich der
Krieg in der Ukraine um nur die
wichtigsten hier zu nennen die uns also
massivst
betreffen und dies dieser Event heute
beleuchtet auch eine Vielzahl von diesen
Konflikten mit einer Schlussfolgerung
welche Auswirkungen wird denn das
insgesamt haben betonne noch einmal wir
von der Wirtschaft erwarten uns hier
eine doch eine
Einordnung wo man sich daran orientieren
kann aber Tatsache ist dass die globalen
Krisenherde relevant zugenommen haben
und die Folgen sind drastisch und sehr
weitreichend und der Global peace Index
des Institutes V economics und peace
zeigt auf dass die Welt zum neunten Mal
weniger friedlich geworden ist ich
formuliere es positiv in 91 Ländern also
knapp in 100 Ländern finden
grenzüberschreitende Konflikte statt und
Gott sei Dank Österreich gehört zu den
fünf friedlichsten Ländern auf dieser
Welt und Krieg und Terror bedeutet
einerseits stehs eine humanitäre
Katastrophe mit enormen Leid
Krieg hat aber auch insgesamt massivste
Auswirkungen auf die Weltwirtschaft und
bringt auch starke Veränderungen in der
Gesellschaft und jetzt haben wir erst
covid gemeinsam gut bewältigt ich glaube
das kann man zu sagen auch wenn es immer
wieder Kritik gibt aber insgesamt und
das sage ich klarerweise für die
Wirtschaft wurde gemeinsam Maßnahmen
umgesetzt die uns gut aus dieser Krise
haben kommen lassen und wo wir wertvolle
Erkenntnisse gewonnen haben und wo wir
für etweige Pandemie in der Zukunft mit
Sicherheit deutlich besser aufgestellt
sind nun unmittelbar auf covid ist
Angriffskrieg Russlands auf die Ukraine
erfolgt und dieser Krieg geht
mittlerweile in das dritte Jahr und ich
bin nochm neben der unglaublichen
Katastrophe die humanitär zu verzeichnen
ist haben wir dramatische
wirtschaftliche Verwerfungen global in
Europa aber auch für Österreich und ich
hatte heute erst in der Früh wieder
Gelegenheit mit einem Regierungsmitglied
das Thema bespre zu besprechen welche
Auswirkungen wir mit jeden Tag
insbesondere im landwirtschaftlichen
Bereich hier zu spüren haben und da
wird's wohl notwendig sein auf der einen
Seite klarerweise weiterhin intensive
Solidarität zu zeigen aber auf der
anderen Seite wird man auch auf der
europäischen Ebene Maßnahmen setzen
müssen die negativen Auswirkungen
betreffen in erster Linie Versorgung mit
Rohstoffen Energie mit starken
Kostenentwicklungen Folge hohinflation
eine geänderte Zinspolitik zwangsläufig
geänderte Zinspolitik am Rande sage ich
viel zu spät begonnen auf Ebene der b
und das betrifft dass wir derzeit kein
Wirtschaftswachstum haben auch in
Österreich sondern eine leichte
Rezession wo wir heuer hoffentlich
wieder in ein leichtes
Wirtschaftswachstum kommen und das alles
spüren die Menschen in diesem Land und
wir haben damit auch
veritable wirtschaftliche Gefahren für
Europa wenn wir an die Logistik Kosten
denken warum weil allein durch den
Sueskanal durch das Rote Meer können die
Schiffe nicht mehr durch den Sueskanal
fahren viele nehmen jetzt den großen
Umweg und das bedeutet wieder dass
Lieferketten allfällig unterbrochen sind
dass jedenfs aber die Preisentwicklungen
bei den Transporten und auch die
Verfügbarkeit ja stark zu hinterfragen
sind
z Kanal werden etwa 12% des Welthandels
abgewickelt als Drehscheibe wichtige
handelsrout und wenn wir gar in das
Südchinesische Meer schauen dann geht's
um ca 30% des
welthandelsvolumens das über diesen
Seeweg transportiert wird und das alles
haben wir als Risiko in der Wirtschaft
weil viele von uns und auch Reifeisen
ist z.B klarerweise in china
investiert da fragt man sich
Globalisierung quowadis wir sehen sehr
klar wie sensibel und verletz sich das
globale wirtschaftsgeflecht geworden ist
und dann fragt man sich steht
Globalisierung noch für Stabilität für
eine stabile Entwicklung auch
insbesondere in der Wirtschaft oder ist
diese für die Wirtschaft mittlerweile zu
einem beachtlichen Sicherheitsrisiko
geworden ich denke die Antwort derzeit
liegt auf der Hand wir müssen verstärkt
Augenmerk legen auf eine Handelspolitik
die Abhängigkeit reduziert und mehr
Resilienz generiert da wird's wohl
notwendig sein dass wir neue Märkte
erschließen müssen zusätzliche Märkte
aber auch vielleicht zu überlegen haben
wie weit wir dezentrale Strukturen in
Europa aber auch in Österreich vermehrt
in Vordergrund rücken müssen Europa und
Österreich muss bestrebt sein wieder
mehr primäre Wertschöpfung und damit
Grundversorgung zurückzuholen meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren die risigen
und Gefahren und gleichzeitig
Herausforderungen mit denen wir es zu
tun haben
sorgen täglich für Verunsicherung auch
in unserer
Bevölkerung und ich bin der Meinung und
wenn ich das mit anderen
wirtschaftsunternehmungen diskutiere
europa muss militärisch wieder zu einem
relevanten Faktor werden und zwar in der
Welt werden wenn uns das nicht gelingt
wird sehr schwierig sein unsere Werte
Essen und
Wirtschafts Dynamik in
Wirtschaftswachstum in der EU in der
Zukunft absichern zu können und damit
bin ich beim Bogen bereits in Österreich
und ich bin unserer Frau Bundesminister
sehr sehr dankbar der österreichische
Bundesregierung hat schon eine klare
Schlussfolgerung gezogen ich sage da ist
eine Zeitenwende
eingetreten es wurde auf die veränderte
Weltordnung auf die sehr unsichere
Weltordnung reagiert und längst
Investitionen in das österreichische
Bundesheer werden durch den neuen
Budgetpfad möglich und noch etwas und
das ist das sehr freuliche Zeitenwende
auch deshalb weil auch die
österreichische Bevölkerung awness
mittlerweile erlangt hat denn Frau
Bundesminister dein Weg von der
österreichischen Bevölkerung massiv
unterstützt
77% haben hohes Vertrauen in das
österreichische Bundesheer und 69% der
österreichischen Bevölkerung
unterstützen auch den Aufbauplan ÖBH
2023 das ist ein starkes Signal
äh und es geht um nichts Geringeres als
um die Sicherheit der Republik
Österreich und was wir natürlich auch
brauchen neben den Investitionen wir in
der Wirtschaft sind auch aufgefordert
nachzudenken wenn man das Thema
umfassende Landesverteidigung hernimmt
und analysiert dann hat auch die
Wirtschaft dabei einen wesentlichen
Beitrag äh zu leisten und daraus
äh sind wohl unabdingbare Maßnahmen für
unsere Sicherheit und somit für den
Schutz unserer demokratischen Werte und
unserer Freiheit äh abzuleiten wir
wissen aber auch das können wir nicht
alleine ich habe es zu Beginn
angesprochen national gibt's große
Unterstützung aber wenn wir alleine an
die agrarströme in Europa denken dann
ist das nur auf der europäischen Ebene
äh in letzter Konsequenz auch dann
steuerbar und regelbar und auf der
militärischen Seite wurde durch den
European skyschield durch diese
Initiative auch sehr sehr klar in den
Raum gestellt dass diese Zusammenarbeit
in Europa im Vordergrund stellt meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren wir haben
unglaublich herausfordernde Zeiten
höchst instabile Sicherheitslage in der
Welt mit Krisenherden dramatischen
Veränderungen äh und Unsicherheit und
ich betone noch einmal das spiegelt sich
auch in der Wirtschaft wieder durch ein
verhaltenes investieren wenn überhaupt
investiert wird und wir haben keine
regulierte Weltordnung in dem Sinn mehr
wir haben auch keine vorwandzeiten mehr
wenn wir vor einigen Jahren noch
vorwandzeiten von 5 bis 10 Jahren
gesprochen haben nein das haben wir
nicht mehr und umso mehr muss es einen
Schulterschluss geben zwischen der
Sicherheitspolitik und der wirtschaftsp
Politik und dann bin ich mir sicher dass
auch unsere Bevölkerung sich nicht nur
sicher fühlt sondern auch in der Zukunft
gut aufgehoben sich fühlt ich wünsche
Ihnen alles Gute weiterhin viel Erfolg
wünsche dieser Veranstaltung alles
erdenklich Gute und ich bin sicher alle
jene die heute hier sind werden
wertvolle Erkenntnisse mit für sich und
für ihre Wirtschaft mitnehmen alles Gute
und vielen
Dank
vielen Dank Herr Hammer Sie dass imm
vollkommen recht das was gerade passiert
hat auf alles und auf jeden wirklich
große Auswirkungen ja das
österreichische bundeser ist und war
schon immer sehr wichtig für Österreich
nicht nur wenn es naturgemäß um Krisen
und Kriege handelt sondern auch bei
Naturkatastrophen Cyberangriffe Terror
und vielen vielen anderen Themen ist das
österreichische Bundeswehr da ja und
jetzt jetzt stehen wir vor großen
wirklich großen Herausforderungen es bed
darf wieder mal hohe Konzentration und
starke Führung wir freuen uns jetzt auf
unsere Bundesministerin Claudia Tanner
sie wird jetzt ihre keyote halten und
wird uns mehr berichten über die
Hintergründe
des risikobildes herzlich willkommen
schön dass Sie da
[Applaus]
sind
Exzellenzen sehr Herr Generalsekretär
Herr
Generalstabschef Herr Bundesminister
außerdienst sehr Gerte whrsprecher
leitende Beamte Beamtinnen meines Hauses
Experten Interessierte an dem was sich
in der Welt tut sehr geehrte
medienvertreterinnen und
Medienvertreter der Titel unseres
diesjährigen risikobildes der sagt wohl
alles noch viel mehr als diese Worte
Welt aus den
Fugen das zeigen uns die Bilder die wir
tagtäglich erleben müssen sei jetzt seit
beinah zi
Jahren aus dem Ukraine Krieg oder aus
dem
nahenosten wo wir Dinge erleben müssen
und mussten die wir wohl so auf diese
Art und Weise nicht für möglich gehalten
haben oder vielleicht
doch eine Keynote brauche ich nach den
Ausführungen unseres milizbeauftragten
Herrn Generalanwalt
und und Herrn Generalmajor Hameseder
wohl nicht mehr halten weil da schon
alles drinnen war und das ist gut so
jedes Jahr nach dieser
sicherheitspolitischen jahresfororscher
stellen wir uns auch
fragen das werden wir auch die dieses
Mal tun und vielleicht finden wir auch
die Antworten sehr oft finden wir auch
die Antworten darauf ob wir uns
entsprechend vorbereitet haben auf all
das was im risikobild zu sehen
ist ich glaube das haben wir in der
Vergangenheit nicht und ich spreche hier
für das österreichische bundesjah auch
das ist schon angesprochen worden wir
haben es ja für selbstverständlich
gehalten dass es auf unserem Kontinent
keinen Krieg mehr geben und dass daher
die militärische
Landesverteidigung sicher nicht mehr im
Zentrum steht das haben sie ja viele so
gesehen und auch danach gehandelt oder
eben nicht gehandelt die Moderatorin hat
auch so treffend formuliert wie ist denn
das Bundesheer wahrgenommen worden in
der Vergangenheit insbesondere durch die
Aufgaben die in Assistenz zu bewältigen
waren und nach wie vor sind nämlich wenn
Naturkatastrophen z.B auftreten auch
eines der groß großen Risiken den
Klimawandel
anbelangend aber all das was sich getan
hat in der Welt das hat doch dazu
geführt dass wir in Österreich handeln
müssen nein gehandelt haben und sehr
Gerte Damen und Herren wenn ich hier in
der ersten Reihe auch die whrsprecher
der Parteien vor mir sehe dann denke ich
doch dass uns etwas gelungen ist das
mehr ist als nur das Wort
Zeitenwende zu nennen zu beschreiben
sondern in Wahrheit auch umzusetzen eine
Zeitenwende jawohl Herr Generalanwalt
habammeder im österreichischen
Bundesheer auch einzuleiten mit
Investitionssummen die wir auf diese Art
und Weise noch nie zu verbrauchen hatten
mit 18 Milliarden Euro allein in den
nächsten 4 Jahren mit einem genau
Aufbauplan aber das wird unser
planungschef ja noch im Detail
darstellen der bis zum Jahr
2032 und darüber hinausgeht da steht ein
Plus dabei verankert in einem Gesetz das
heißt mit dem
landesverteidigungsfinanzierungsgesetz
nicht nur zu denken bis zur zum Ende der
Legislaturperiode sondern darüber hinaus
gemeinsam
entsprechende Maßnahmen zu setzen und
diese auch zu verankern dass sie nicht
mehr rückgängig zu machen sind wir sind
mitten in der Umsetzung mitten in der
Umsetzung der Investitionen ich schaue
jetzt unseren erdschiff an weil erst
einige Tage her ist dass wir unser
großes hubschrauberpaket noch einmal
präsentieren durften weil wir die erste
Einsatzfähigkeit bei unseren Leonardo
hergestellt haben das ist die größte
Investition nach den eurofitn die wir in
Österreich jemals getätigt haben aber
wir investieren auch in unser
panzerpaket ich glaube Herr Minister
außerdienst lieber Werner das ist da im
übrigen das erste nach deiner
ministerperiode dass wir mit insgesamt
560 Millionen Euro auf die Straße
bringen wo wir unsere Leopard und unsere
an unsere Kampf und Schützenpanzer auf
den modernsten Stand wiederbringen ja
und wir investieren auch in unsere
Infrastruktur ich war jetzt soeben
gemeinsam mit dem Militärkommandanten
von Wien bei der stellungsstraße in Wien
bei der neugebauten
stellungsstraße wo wir die ersten
grundwerdiener die heute dort zur
Untersuchung angesagt waren auch
aufsuchen durften und man sieht schon
wie lange wir nicht gehandelt haben hier
in Österreich daran dass das das erste
Gebäude auf einer militärischen
Liegenschaft ist dass wir eben vor
kurzen eröffnet haben das erste nach
beinah 10 Jahren in diesen drei
Bereichen investieren
wir das müssen wir sehr sehr rasch tun
weil eben die Krisen und die Bedrohungen
mehr geworden sind und eine
Schnelligkeit auch erfordern ich glaube
wir sind auf einem sehr guten Weg dank
unseres rüstungschefssal der
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter die
hier ihre Kompetenzen einbringen das
alles hilft uns aber nichts wenn wir
nicht das entsprechende Personal haben
und wenn heute schon angesprochen worden
ist der Tag der werpflichttern bin ich
überzeugt davon dass die
Österreicherinnen und Österreicher
damals 2013 eine sehr richtige und
weitreichende Entscheidung getroffen
haben das sieht man ja wo so viele
andere Staaten jetzt wieder daran denken
oder dabei sind die Wehrpflicht wieder
einzuführen wir haben damit die
Möglichkeit über 16000
junge Männer und ja wir haben auch den
Freiwilligen grundwerrdienst für Frauen
eingeführt im April des vergangenen
Jahres und Frauen dafür zu begeistern
für das österreichische Bundesheer weil
wir dieses Personal auch brauchen damit
auch das ist die Basis für unser bundesj
aber auch für die Miliz und dafür Herr
Generalanwalt da brauchen wir auch das
Verständnis der Wirtschaft dass uns hier
ganz eng auch begleiten die uns ja ganz
eng auch begleiten muss auf diesem Weg
auch die ersten Investitionen in die
Miliz die wir damals mit vor dreieinhalb
Jahren mit dem milizpaket getroffen
haben glaube wir sind mit unserer
Mission vorwärts durchaus auf einem
guten Weg aber all diesen Risiken und
wenn die Welt aus den Fugen geraten ist
denen können wir nur gemeinsam beggegnen
nicht alleinstehend hier in Europa
sondern indem wir auch erkennen dass wir
die europäischen
verteidigungskapazitäten erweitern
müssen das das strategische Kompass
nicht nur ein zahnloser papierdieger
bleiben darf dass wir tatsächlich auch
unseren Beitrag leisten werden wenn wir
die eurapit deployment capacity jetzt
auf den Weg bringen und auch trotz dem
risikobild das lautet hier in Österreich
fokussiert auf das Innland fokussiert
auf die auuslandseinsitze aber stark im
Inland nicht zu vernachlässigen und
weiter ein glaubwürdiger Partner auch zu
sein bei
Missionen bei allen Friedens
friedenserhaltenden Missionen rund um
die ganze Welt und sehr geehrte Damen
und Herren wenn wir die Bilder sehen
gerade was Luftverteidigung anbelangt
wenn wir die Bilder sehen mit welchen
Mitteln dieser Krieg jetzt fortgeführt
auch wird gegen die Ukraine mit
ballistischen Raketen mit Drohnen mit
allem
was man zur Verfügung hat dann ist es
eine
Notwendigkeit dass wir diese
luftverteidigungskapazitäten in allen
Reichweiten entweder aufbauen oder
überhaupt erst ausbauen das müssen wir
tun das ist unsere Verantwortung dass
wir mit dabei sind bei diesem
Beschaffungsprogramm das darf keine
Lücke sein die hier über Österreich
besteht und ich bin tatsächlich
Deutschland sehr dankbar für diese
Initiative an der so viele europäische
Staaten mittlerweile beteiligt sind weil
gerade diese
luftverteidigungskapazitäten auch
gestärkt werden müssen in Zukunft das
Konzept der umfassenden
Landesverteidigung ist schon erwähnt
worden ich glaube dass es eines ist dass
wir tatsächlich auch mit Leben erfüllen
müssen und wir haben bereits damit
begonnen die wirtschaftliche
Landesverteidigung ist auch schon
angesprochen worden die wird uns
unglaublich fordern aber sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren auch die geistige
Landesverteidigung wird ein Thema sein
wenn wir miterleben müssen wie
autoritäre Systeme sich durchsetzen egal
in welchem Bereich der Welt wenn wir zur
Kenntnis nehmen müssen wie wenig
geschätzt wird insbesondere von der
zukünftigen Generation dass wir in einer
Demokratie leben dann haben einen sehr
großen Weg noch vor uns wir haben den
bereits eingeleitet indem wir die
umfassende Landesverteidigung die
geistige Landesverteidigung auch wieder
in den Lehrplänen der Schulen verankert
haben und auch der heutige Tag an dieser
Stelle ein ganz großes Dankeschön unsere
Abteilungsleiterin Magister Anger Bauer
weil wir dieses Mal auch dieses Dokument
unser risikobild den Schulen den
Universitäten zur Verfügung stellen
damit die hier auch ein sprechenden
Einblick bekommen das heißt
nicht nur von Dingen zu reden diese
irgendwo in Papieren vorzufinden sondern
in Wahrheit
anzupacken das tun wir das tun wir
gemeinsam jeder und jede einzelne von
ihnen hat seinen Beitrag dazu geleistet
insbesondere zu unserem Risiko Bericht
geleistet die Expertinnen und Experten
meines Hauses aber insbesondere auch die
die mit beigetragen haben hier zu diesem
wor Wort Werk und heute auch Rede und
Antwort hier stehen und ich bin
überzeugt davon dass auch diese
sicherheitspolitische jahresforscher
dazu führen wird dass unsere Welt ein
Stückchen sicherer werden wird ich denke
dennoch auch wenn die Welt aus den Fugen
geraten ist dann sollten wir selber das
nicht tun sondern wir sollten fokussiert
bleiben und umsetzen das österreichische
Bundesheer stark zu machen zu erkennen
dass Verteidigung auch heißt eine
wichtige Rolle im europäischen Bereich
zu spielen und seinen Beitrag zu leisten
dass man sehr wohl als neutraler Staat
durchaus militärisch neutral sein kann
aber nicht gleichgültig wenn es darum
geht wenn Völkerrecht verletzt wird und
Staatsgrenzen außer Kraft gesetzt werden
bin überzeugt davon dass wir all diesen
Risiken nur mit der Zusammenarbeit
begegnen können das ist der Schlüssel in
Wahrheit für alles bin überzeugt davon
dass gerade dass gerade dieser heutige
Tag auch wieder dazu beitragen wird
unseren Blick zu schärfen dass man
diesen Risiken auch begegnen kann dass
wir uns breit aufstellen müssen so wie
wir das als österreichisches Bundesheer
auch tun daher abschließend ein ganz
großes Dankeschön an unseren
Generalsekretär und Direktor für
Verteidigungspolitik dr Kammel an Herrn
Generalmajor vorhofer und an unsere
Abteilungsleiterin Angerbauer darüber
hinaus an all diejenigen die mitgewirkt
haben dass wir heute diesen Tag erleben
dürfen und die entsprechenden
Erkenntnisse daraus ziehen werden und
wie eingangs mir gewünscht auf die eine
oder andere Frage die wir uns stellen in
einer Welt die aus den Fugen geraten ist
auch Antworten finden können ich danke
Ihnen ja vielen lieben Dank Frau
Bundesministerin also es gibt viel zu
tun es liegt viel Arbeit vor uns und
einer der das auch gut einschätzen kann
ist unser Generalmajor dr Peter vorhofer
den ich jetzt auf die Bühne bitte sie
wollen jetzt und werden jetzt die key
messages uns berichten vom risikob
Österreich 24 danke
schön sehr geehrte Frau Bundesminister
Herr Generalsekretär Herr
generalstopchef generaler heseder meine
Damen und Herren mit jedem Jahresbeginn
stellt das Bundesministerium für
Landesverteidigung das risikobild da und
im heurigen Jahr und mit dem Titel wie
wir es versehen haben ist das Interesse
und die Erwartungshaltung aus unserer
Sicht sehr hoch in den letzten Jahren
ist es uns gelungen viel vorher zu sagen
richtig vorher zu sagen und wir hoffen
dass wir auch Heu wieder ihnen
hochqualitative Aussagen präsentieren
können muss aber schon sagen dass ziel
und Zweck dieser ganzen Veranstaltung
ist eine gewisse Reaktions und
Präventionsmaßnahme daraus
abzuleiten für uns ist der wichtigste
Aspekt die it die Validität unserer
Aussagen und ich glaube dass das
bundesminstum für Landesverteidigung
hier in den letzten Jahren methodisch
eine sehr sehr hohe Kompetenz entwickeln
konnte zur Vertiefung und die Frau
Bundesminister hat schon angesprochen
liegen unsere ausgedruckten
schriftlichen Varianten auch noch vor wo
sie sich einlesen können bevor ich in
Kurzform die Risiken beschreiben und
kurz erklären werde und es ist heute
schon angesprochen worden wir müssen uns
und meine Experten und ich machen das
natürlich mit diesem großen megat Trend
auseinandersetzen nämlich die
Umstrukturierung unserer
Weltordnung und viele Risiken die wir
heute sehen werden haben sozusagen ihren
Ursprung darin das entscheidende meine
Damen und Herren ist aber wir werden mit
dieser Unordnung dieser Welt Minimum
zwei Dekaden brauchen das ist die
unterste Grenze wie lange dieser Vorgang
dauern wird und es gibt bereits
Auswirkungen und Effekte die sie
persönlich alle selbst feststellen und
beobachten können ich werde dazu noch
später kommen sie sehen hinter mir eine
Bandbreite der Risiken die wir
analysieren und
beobachten und ich stelle Ihnen heute
acht davon vor die relevantesten und die
Relevanz setzt sich zusammen aus der
Eintrittswahrscheinlichkeit und dem
Schadensumfang beginnen möchte ich mit
dem ersten Risiko dass das militärische
Konflikte immer mehr Auswirkungen auf
Österreich haben werden und meine Damen
und Herren das möchte ich schon noch
auch
betonen es werden die militärischen und
bewaffneten Konflikte mehr werden warum
ist das
so weil der Krieg als Dimension der
Politik zurück
ist weil neue Mächte auf dieser Welt mit
sehr sehr viel Selbstvertrauen ihre
Interessen auch kriegerisch und
bewaffnet umsetzen wollen und
schließlich und endlich meine Damen und
Herren wir befinden uns in einer
globalen
Aufrüstung also drei ganz wesentliche
Punkte worum das passieren wird das
nächste Risiko die Konfrontation
Russlands mit der Europäischen Union und
die Möglichkeit einer Eskalierung meine
Damen und Herren nach klauswitz ist der
Krieg ein Akt der Gewalt um den Gegner
zur Erfüllung des eigenen Willens zu
zwingen derzeit in diesem Konflikt nicht
absehbar daher
anhaltend die Ideen zu möglichen
Friedensgesprächen scheitern daran dass
die
grundfaktoren Territorium und
Sicherheitsgarantie derzeit
unrealistisch sind das dritte ist auf
militärstrategischer Ebene die Faktoren
Kraft Raum Zeit und
Technologie derzeit für ke eineine Seite
einen extremen Vorteil bieten und meine
Damen und Herren die konfliktlen Linken
sehr sehr nahe beieinander das bedeutet
dass wir
2024 mit einer großen Wahrscheinlichkeit
starke Hybride Kriegsführung erleben
werden das nächste Risiko ist die
strategiefähigkeit und meine Damen und
Herren das ist nicht ein
österreichisches Risiko sondern ein
Risiko das viele Länder betrifft und es
ist deshalb v weil natürlich im
Unterschied zu den Zeiten des Kalten
Krieges und Phasen danach die
Vorhersehbarkeit der Sicherheitspolitik
dort leichter und einfacher war jetzt
passiert folgendes wir haben ein
Zusammenwirken verschiedener Risiken zu
gleich und wir haben eine Vermehrung des
bekannten unbekannten und des
Unbekannten
unbekannten und für die Strategiefindung
noch besonders herausfordern ist die
komplexe Welt
der zivilen Seite mit der komplexen Welt
des militärischen zu verbinden es ist
heute schon ein bisschen andiskutiert
worden das nächste Risiko sind die
Lieferketten und Sie können das ja
jederzeit im Fernsehen nachvollziehen
was vor allem hier im im Roten Meer und
ähnlichen Räumen dieser Welt passiert
eines muss man auch sagen diese
weltumbruchsphase betrifft natürlich
auch die Wirtschaft und das bedeutet
dass wir wahrscheinlich mit einer großen
Fr tierung der Weltwirtschaft zu rechnen
haben in der nächsten Zeit wir haben
wahrscheinlich neue Handelsbeziehungen
unter neuen Aspekten zu erwarten near
shoring fr shoring um sozusagen
Abhängigkeiten von anderen zu reduzieren
und wir haben meine Damen und Herren sie
kennen das vielleicht Brix Brix plus
neue Akteure auf dieser Welt die
mehr interessens geleitet als Werte
geleitet versuchen die Welt umzuändern
in Wirtschaft ichen Hinblick das nächste
Risiko die Migrationsströme nach
Österreich meine Damen und Herren auch
wenn es jetzt ein bisschen ruhiger
geworden ist das wird trotzdem bleiben
und ansteigen weil die strukturellen
Ursachen für Vertreibung und Flucht sich
nicht geändert haben und es ist nach wie
vor so dass der globale Süden
benachteiligt ist und die
demographischen Entwicklungen in diesen
Räumen produzieren
unweigerlich eine Flucht nach
Europa das nächste Risiko das uns
betreffen wird ist die
souveränitätsgefährdung durch
Cyberangriffe und der Kampf in
computernetzwerker meine Damen und
Herren ich sage hier nichts Neues wenn
wir alle feststellen dass die
Informationstechnik Teil unseres Lebens
geworden ist aber damit ist sie auch
Ziel ein lohnendes Ziel für Akteure
geworden und die Sphäre zwischen Krieg
und Frieden das das ein bisschen
beschreibt ist ja jetzt total verbreitet
und wir sind mittend drinnen und das
bedeutet natürlich auch dass dieser
ganze Raum für militärische
Zielerreichungen extrem wertvoll ist
leider Gottes und zusätzlich tritt ein
Aspekt ein dass wir im
cyberraum verdeckt vorgehen können vor
allem wenn es gegen unsere westlichen
demokratischen starten
geht das siebte Risiko und fast schon
ein bisschen eine Logik daraus
abgeleitet das Risiko der
informationsoperationen und
Desinformationskampagnen meine Damen und
Herren es war noch nie so billig und
noch nie so leicht synthetische Inhalte
zu
generieren daher ist es
informationsumfeld zu einer
militärischen Domäne geworden und
tionskriegsführung ist von ganz enormer
und wichtiger Entscheidung für eine
Auseinandersetzung und daher ein
exzellentes Mittel um Demokratien zu
unterminieren und meine Damen und Herren
wir seind im Jahr 2024 ein Superwahljahr
und es wäre äußerst ungewöhnlich wenn
diese Dinge 2024 nicht zum Tragen kommen
würden letztes Risiko aus unserer Sicht
von großer Relevanz ist die Schwächung
der europäischen Integration durch
externe Akteure vor allem es ist heute
schon leicht angesprochen worden wir
gehören in ein westliches Wertesystem
vor allem Europa und das bekommt derzeit
auf der Welt ganz große Konkurrenz und
ein riesen Vorteil ist dagegen zu
ugieren dass der Integrationsprozess der
von innen heraus unterminiert wird für
Akteure extrem viel Vorteile bietet
und eines soll auch noch gesagt werden
und genau Hamer hat es glaube ich schon
angesprochen es soll auch verhindert
werden dass Europa die Europäische Union
zu einem wesentlichen Sicherheits und
außenpolitischen Akteur in dieser Welt
werden soll meine Damen und Herren ich
habe kurz am Anfang erwähnt es gibt
bereits Auswirkungen Effekte die sie
alle selber beobachten können ich werde
in ein oder anderen erwähnen um Ihnen zu
zeigen was ich damit meine
beginnen wir mit dem sogenannten
weaponizing Effekt der weaponizing
Effekt besagt nichts anders dass wir
eigentlich eine unkontrollierte
Aufrüstung derzeit in der Welt haben wir
haben einen sogenannten new powers
Effekt das bedeutet dass wir Mächte in
der Welt haben die ihre Interessen
beginnen nachhaltig und das bedeutet oft
auch militärisch umzusetzen und das in
einer ungeregelten
Welt das dritte ist einen
antiinstitutioneneffekt der bedeutet
dass sozusagen die grundsatzussage dass
wenn wir uns verplechten friedlich
zueinander sind wird derzeit gerade
wesentlich
unterminiert wir haben einen
spaltungseffekt das bedeutet dass
Organisation an einem Wertesystem
zugeordnet wird Beispiel G7 westliche
Hemisphäre Shanghai Forum östliche und
somit das auch ein konkurrenzverhäl wird
wir haben einen realismuseffekt der
besagt dass Abschreckung wieder zurück
ist und Frieden mit nichtkrieg definiert
wird und schließlich und endlich haben
wir auch einen sicherheitspolitisch und
ökologischen kipppunkteffekt der besagt
dass Globalisierung dort ihr Ende findet
wo die Existenz der Menschheit auf dem
Spiel steht abschließend vielleicht noch
den supporffekt der uns bes sagt und das
sage jetzt mal ganz frei heraus
Europa die Frage
stellt mit wem und was stellen wir uns
eigentlich die Zukunft vor nach Ende
dieses Prozesses und das wird
unterstützt durch einen sogenannten
polycrisen Effekt und Sie merken das
alle meine Damen und Herren glaube sie
sind sehr viele Experten da hier im Raum
dass also die Funktion von großen
internationalen Organisation in der
Konfliktbewältigung Friedenssicherung
immer stärker zurückgedrängt wird und
abschließend befinden wir uns in einer
battle of offers das bedeutet vor allem
für den globalen Süden dass sie andere
alternative Systeme haben und somit der
westliche demokratische liberale
Ansatz extrem unter druckgät und daher
sich daraus sehr sehr viele Änderungen
ergeben meine Damen und Herren wir haben
außerhalb und ich habe außerhalb dieser
analysierten Risiken glaube ich noch
drei weitere die ich Ihnen gerne näher
bringen möchte das ist erstens wir haben
sowas wie eine nostal ein
nostalgierisiko das beschreibt den
Umstand das vor allem in Europa und ich
möchte das betonen das bezieht sie
vorrangig auf europäische Gesellschaften
das bezieht sie darauf dass wir 30
Jahre uns an ein System der friedlichen
t und interessensbewältigung gewöhnt
haben daraus abgeleitet gibt es sowas
wie einen wie ein träheitsrisiko es ist
klar der inherente Wunsch von
Gesellschaften sich nicht ändern zu
müssen oder Anpassungen in großen Ausmaß
durchführen zu müssen und jetzt kommt
der entsche das entscheidende Risiko des
gestaltungs und
innovationsrisiko das bedeutet die Frage
unter welchen Umständen will in dem Fall
Europa diese neue Weltordnung
mitgestalten und interessensgeleitet
bestimmen meine Damen und Herren und
wenn wir zum Ende drei
Schlussfolgerungen ziehen möchten auf
einer kognitiven Ebene auf einer
materiellen Ebene und einer personellen
Ebene könnten wir drei
Schlussfolgerungen ziehen um die
Resilienz Österreichs zu stärken aber
gilt auch für Europa erstens
Vorbereitung zweitens
Vorbereitung drittens Vorbereitung ich
danke für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit vielen Dank Herr
Generalmajor für die spannenden
überblicke und auch messages die Sie uns
jetzt aus dem Bericht schon präsentiert
haben ich darf überleiten zum
hochgätigen Panel und darf als erst
herzlich grüßen Gerhard mangott er ist
ein österreichcher
Politikwissenschaftler Professor für
Politikwissenschaft an der Universität
Innsbruck sein Forschungsschwerpunkt auf
der Sicherheitsforschung im
postsowjetischen Raum also liegt auf dem
postsowjetischen Raum insbesondere seit
dem Beginn des russischen angriffsrieges
auf der Ukraine im Februar 22 Professor
mangot uns allen ein Begriff und ständig
Experte im Fernsehen und in den Medien
herzlich willkommen be
uns sie dürfen gerne schon mal Platz
nehmen weiters begrüßen wir sehr
herzlich die Marie Janine Kit sie ist
Historikerin politikberaterin und
Professorin für die Geschichte Ost und
Südeuropas an der Universität in München
sie ist eine der führenden ExpertInnen
für Konflikte in Südosteuropa
insbesondere für Westbalkan für den
westbalkanraum und wir heißen Sie auch
sehr herzlich hier willkommen Frau
Professor gerne hier Platz
nehmen weiters begrüßen wir die Antonia
sie ist promovierte
Politikwissenschaftlerin und
forschungsgruppenleiterin für African
Intervention politics am leibnis
Institut für Friedens und
Konfliktforschung sie hat viele Jahre in
Afrika gelebt und wird uns da auch einen
Überblick der für Österreich relevanten
Krisenregionen jetzt geben herzlich
Willkommen bei uns
Frau dann begrüßen wir auch sehr
herzlich Günther Barnett er ist
Fachexperte für regionale Strategie und
Programmentwicklung in der generald tion
der Verteidigungspolitik sein Hauptfokus
liegt auf den Fachbereichen regionale
Angelegenheiten
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit sowie
verteidigungspolitische Beitrag zum
internationalen Krisenmanagement schön
dass Sie da
sind und die Runde komplementiert der
Günther Hofbauer erst Generalmajor und
stellvertretender Generalstabschef und
Chefplaner des österreichischen
bundesehers und wird uns auch zum Plan
2022 plus etwas sagen herzlich
willkommenur durch genau ich glaub ich
glaub ich weiß nicht ja sonst machen wir
so genau Wasser ist da genau Mikrofone
dürfen sie einfach nehmen die werden
dann von der Technik sofort
eingeschaltet und wir haben mir gesagt
wir wollen uns die Krisen und
kriegsregionen anschauen die für
Österreich relevant sind und wir
beginnen auch in der Reihenfolge wie es
die Einladung vorgeschrieben hat ich
würde gern bei Professor mangot anfangen
seit fast zwei Jahren läuft dieser
Angriffskrieg von Russland auf die
Ukraine was können Sie uns über 2023
zunächst sagen wie hat sich der
Angriffskrieg entwickelt was waren die
größten Herausforderungen und wo stehen
wir jetzt schönen Vormittag meine Damen
und Herren Frau Bundesministerin nun
2023 hat eigentlich begonnen mit großen
Erwartungen und Hoffnungen genähert
durch die erfolgreichen gegenoffensiven
der ukrainischen Armee in der Region
harkiv und in der Region herson eine
offensive die dann letztlich im Juni des
vergangenen Jahres begonnen hat aber
diese Offensive hat an der Frontlinie
kaum Veränderungen gebracht es gab gab
Vorstöße der Ukraine in der Region
saporiche bei robotine es gab ein
Vorstoß auf das östliche Ufer des nipro
es gab einige Vorstöße in der Region um
die Stadt bachmut aber die Frontlinie
hat sich kaum verändert es wäre aber
trotzdem falsch zu sagen dass die
Offensive völlig gescheitert wäre wie
das manche Beobachter meine denn die
Ukraine hat sehr wohl im rückwärtigen
Raum einiges an Erfolgen erzielen können
mit der Zerstörung von Kommandozentralen
von Hauptquartieren von
Versorgungslinien von munitions und
Waffendepots aber auch das gilt es zu
erwähnen die buchstäbliche Vertreibung
der russischen Schwarzmeerflotte von der
Krim in den Osten des Schwarzen Meeres
nun diese Offensive eben mit vielen
Erwartungen verbunden war auch immer mit
der Sorge verbunden dass wenn sie nicht
gelingt und dass sie im Wesentlichen
eben nicht gelungen ist habe ich
geschildert der Druck aus manchen
westlichen Staaten zunehmen wird dass
die Ukraine nicht mehr auf einen
militärischen Sieg setzt wie das ihr
Kriegsziel ist sondern dass es zu einem
verhandlungskompromiss kommen sollte zu
einer Art Waffenruhe zunächst unter
bestimmten Bedingungen dieser Druck ist
sicherlich größer geworden durch das was
wir militärisch 2023 gesehen haben und
was für 2024 zu erwarten ist nämlich das
was wir eine aktive
Verteidigungsstellung der Ukraine nennen
das heißt zumindest die Kapazitäten
aufzubauen und zum Teil zu bewahren um
die Frontlinie zu halten und dann die
Optimisten rechnen mit einer möglichen
neuen ukrainischen Offensive
im Jahr 2025 nun die Offensive ist auch
deswegen an der Frontline nicht sehr
erfolgreich gewesen weil die surokin
Linien also die gestaffelte
Verteidigungslinie der russischen Armee
so stark war und auch aus bestimmten
Umständen so stark ausgebaut werden
konnte es gibt auch Kritik daran dass
die Ukraine an mehreren Frontabschnitten
angegriffen hat manche meinen sie hätte
in der Region saborisia konzentriert
angreifen sollen um dann nach dokm und
Melitopol vorzustoßen es gibt auch die
Kritik aus der Ukraine der Westen hab zu
wenig zu spät an Waffen geliefert und
was es auch gibt die Ukraine hat und das
wird sich verschärfen massive
Rekrutierungsprobleme für die
Streitkräfte es wird derzeit in der
wchoven radaer im Parlament ein Gesetz
diskutiert über die Mobilisierung von
bis zu 500.000 Soldaten das ist etwas
was sehr umstritten ist zwischen
militärischer und politischer Führung
selenski hält sich sehr zurück mit
Unterstützung dieses großen
mobilisierungsprojektes das auch sehr
teuer sein würde etwa 13 Milliarden
Dollar verschlingen würde und spielt
eigentlich der den Streitkräften vor
allem general soluschni dem
Oberbefehlshaber der ukrainischen
Streitkräfte die Verantwortung zu für
diese auch durchaus unpopuläre
Mobilisierung und das ist auch etwas was
wir beobachten müssen es gibt zunehmende
Konflikte zwischen der zivilen und der
politischen Führung in der Ukraine und
es gibt auch Anzeichen dafür dass im
Parlament dieser Burgfrieden zwischen
den verschiedenen Parteien der Ukraine
langsam aufzubrechen beginnt nicht nur
aber eben auch gerade an diesem neuen
mobilisierungsgesetz nun wo stehen wir
jetzt wir sind jedenfalls jetzt in einem
Punkt wo eine verhandlungsperspektive
nicht besteht es sagen zwar beide
Parteien wir sind verhandlungsbereit
aber sie stellen dafür Vorbedingungen
die für die jeweils andere Seite nicht
akzeptabel sind die Ukraine sagt wir
verhandeln mit der russischen Seite erst
wenn alle russischen Soldaten das
ukrainische Territorium verlassen haben
und das wäre gleichbedeutend mit einer
desaströsen Kriegsniederlage Russlands
und über sollte dann verhandelt werden
das gilt auch für die ukrainische
friedensformel die nachvollz ist
nachvollziehbar ist inhaltlich aber die
letztlich einen Siegfrieden braucht den
ich nicht sehe für die ukrainische Seite
und Russland sagt wir sind bereit zu
verhandeln aber nur wenn die ukrainische
Regierung aus dem russischen übersetzt
die Realitäten am Boden anerkennt
nämlich dass die Regionen herson
saporisia donjk und luhansk nun Teil des
russischen Staatsgebietes sind was die
ukrainische Führung völlig
verständlicherweise ablhnt keine
territorialen Zugeständnisse und das
gilt auch für die große Mehrheit der
Bevölkerung Konzept Land für Frieden ist
etwas von ein was von einer großen
mehrit der Bevölkerung abgelehnt wird um
noch etwas zu sagen für über ukrainische
Aktivitäten die Ukraine hat es im
letzten Jahr doch immer wieder geschafft
Grenzregionen Russlands anzugreifen mit
verschiedenen Waffensystemen
Grenzregionen wie Kursk briansk rastof
waronisch oder vor allem belgorot und
sie hat den Krieg auch ein Stück weit
nach Russland getragen das war auch ein
politisches Ziel denn in Russland gibt
es vor allem in den großen Städten schon
so den Eindruck es gibt gar keinen Krieg
jebenfalls berührte uns überhaupt nicht
und eine Absicht der ukrainischen
Gegenangriffe völkerrechtlich natürlich
völlig erlaubt auf russisches
Territorium ist zum einen der russischen
Bevölkerung zu sagen ihr könnt euch
nicht distanzieren und Denken der Krieg
findet irgendwo da unten statt sondern
wir bringen euch den Krieg nach Hause
und das zweite Ziel ist sicherlich auch
deutlich zu machen dass äh die der
russische Staat die eigenen Bürger und
Bürgerinnen nicht vollständig schützen
kann in diesem Krieg die ich glaube ich
muss zum Schluss kommen die große Frage
ist jetzt äh was sind die Kriegsziele
noch in diesem Krieg die offizielle
westliche Position ist immer es ist
alleine an der Ukraine die Kriegsziele
zu definieren und das ist diplomatisch
auch richtig so das zu sagen aber es ist
natürlich nicht richtig inhaltlich
natürlich bestimmter Westen mit der
Lieferung von bestimmten Waffen in
bestimmter Stückzahl und der
Nichtlieferung bestimmter Waffen da äh
darüber wozu die ukrainische Armee
befähigt wird was sie militärisch
erreichen kann und da gibt es eben in
der Politik Unterschiede zwischen jenen
die sagen wir müssen das Maximalziel der
Ukraine unterstützen vollständige
Rückgewinnung des Territoriums von vor
2014 und andere die sagen nein das ist
militärisch nicht erreichbar und es
könnte mit eskalationsrisiken verbunden
sein horizontal vertikal die wir nicht
riskieren sollten und dieser Streit über
die Kriegsziele und der Streit darüber
wozu wir die Ukraine is Armee befäigen
das ist im Augenblick etwas das die
Sache dominiert vor allem auch vor
demter Hintergrund dass wir in den USA
und Europa heftige Diskussionen haben
über Finanz und Militärhilfe an die
Ukraine ich wollte sagen wie inwiefern
hat sich auch die Rolle selenskis im
Jahr 2023 verändert im Laufe des Jahres
in in seinem Land aber auch in der Welt
nun vor Beginn des Krieges hat selenski
noch eine Zustimmungsrate von 23% gehabt
der hatte die Wahlen im März 2019 mit
73% der Wählerstimmen gewonnen nach dem
Angriff von vor allem seiner
Führungsrolle auch der Entscheidung dass
er in Kiev bleibt ist seine Zustimmung
auf über 90% angewachsen aber wir
bemerken eben im Jahr 2023 dass die
Unterstützung nachgibt Unterstützung
liegt jetzt bei 62% und wir müssen sagen
general soluschni hat eine deutlich
höhere Popularität sie liegt bei 84% und
es gibt so etwas wie einen politischen
Kampf zwischen diesen beiden
vor allem für die Zeit nach dem Krieg
für die anstehenden Präsidentenwahl in
der Ukraine wer wird werden selenski
oder saluschni Sie haben die personellen
Probleme angesprochen das heißt auch
dass Russland langfristig am längeren
Hebel
sitzt der Rekrutierung V was die
Rekrutierung anbelangt sicher die
Bevölkerung ist mehr als dreimal so groß
als die ukrainische Bevölkerung die
Rekrutierungsmethoden sind auch brutaler
auf russischer
Seite ich glaube nicht dass der
kriegswille auf der russischen Seite
größer ist als auf der ukrainischen
Seite im Gegenteil wieewohl man sagen
muss diese ganze Euphorie der vielen
Freiwilligen die nach Kriegsbeginn an
die Front gedrängt haben die ist die ist
dahin aber in diesem Sinne kann Russland
eben mit der Rekrutierung sicherlich
besser punkten die Wirtschaft läuft gut
natürlich durch die heftigen
Investitionen in die Rüstungsindustrie
Wachstum von 3,5% im Jahr
2023 und nur unter Anführungszeichen
eine Rezession von 2,1% im Jahr 2022 und
von der Stimmung der Bevölkerung her
muss man sagen nach den Daten des Levada
Zentrums Z Moska sind jedenfalls noch
ungefähr 70% der Russen Russinen hinter
dieser sogenannten speziellen
Militäroperation wenn nach der Rückhalt
bei diesen 70% unterschiedlich stark ist
manche favorisieren das sehr stark
manche die zck mit den Achsel und nehmen
das einfach zur Kenntnis aber noch ist
die Zustimmung stark nur muss man auch
sagen die Zahl der Russen und Russinen
die für Friedensverhandlungen plediert
ist ständig im steigen und die jetzt
höher als die Zahl derer die für die
Fortsetzung des Krieges eintreten danke
für die seits wir schauen runter zum
Balkan Frau Professor kalid da gab es
jetzt auch in der letzten Zeit
Spannungen die immer stärker wurden wie
sind diese Spannungen denn
einzuschätzen ja vielen Dank meine Damen
und Herren ich
möchte ich möchte diese Frage in drei
Schritten mit drei Argumenten
beantworten erstens die veränderte
geopolitische Situation die neuen
Risiken haben massive Auswirkungen auf
die Region haben zur Verschärfung der
ethnischen Spannungen und
Konfliktlage auf dem Balkan beigetragen
wir haben gesehen dass die russische
Propaganda massiv Fuß gefasst hat in
jenen Ländern die eine deutliche
orthodoxe Mehrheitsbevölkerung haben
also Serbien Montenegro die bosnischen
Serben Mazedonien
auch weniger beachtet ist dass auch der
Krieg im Gaza mittlerweile Auswirkungen
zeigt die Stimmungen beeinflusst dort wo
muslimische Bevölkerung lebt ist der
Antisemitismus stark angewachsen es ist
ein politischer
mobilisierungsfaktor geworden das
betrifft nicht nur Bosnien das betrifft
auch
nordmazedonien und Albanien zu guter
Letzt China ist über die Politik der
neuen Seitenstraße ein wichtiger Akteur
geworden mittlerweile der mich der
wichtigste gläubigerstaat in der Region
was bedeutet dass zukünftig alle
Konflikte die sich in China um China
herum abspielen auch sein Rückwirkungen
haben werden auf die Regionen und das
bringt mich zu meinem zweiten Argument
dem was ich nenne Konflikt drereieck
zwischen Serbien Bosnien und Kosovo
diese drei Länder verhalten sich wie
kommunizierende Röhren das bedeutet
Entwicklungen in dem einen ein einen
Land haben
immer auch Rückwirkungen in den beiden
anderen Serbien steht gewissermaßen im
Mittelpunkt dort hat Präsident Alexander
wutsit in vorgezogenen Neuwahlen
unlängst wieder eine Mehrheit erlangt
ist im Amt bestätigt worden wuic hat in
den letzten Jahren ein System aufgebaut
das seh stark jenem von Viktor Orban in
Ungarn ähnelt das er kontrolliert den
öffentlichen Raum und die Medien und was
uns da beunruhigen muss ist dass die
nationalistische Rhetorik und
revanschistische Rhetorik zugenommen hat
gerade auch im Zusammenhang mit dem
Wahlkampf es ist in Serbien neuerdings
viel von der sogenannten serbischen Welt
die Rede das erinnert uns an Putins
russische Welt und damit soll gesagt
sein dass Serbien eine Verantwortung hat
für die außerhalb der serbischen ganzen
lebenden serbischen Bevölkerungsteile
sprich in Bosnien und im Kosovo und
darüber hinaus serbische Welt meint auch
dass es eine langfristige Perspektive
gibt diese Gebiete wieder mit Serbien zu
vereinigen früher nannte man das
Großserbien der Begriff ist verbrannt
serbische Welt klingt besser und das hat
seine Rückwirkungen wie wir sehen ganz
konkret in den Nachbarländern in Bosnien
und im Kosovo äh im Kosovo ist es im
letzten Jahr verschiedentlich im früher
und dann im September noch mal zu
gewaltsamen Ausschreitungen gekommen die
nicht nur vor Ort Opfer gefordert haben
sondern auch KAV Soldaten natosoldaten
in Mitleidenschaft gezogen haben in
Reaktion auf Kommunalwahlen im Norden
Kosovos
m serbien hat Truppen verlegt an die
Grenze zum Kosovo das hat sorgen
geschürt serbien hat gleichzeitig
dementiert es wollle militärisch
eingrenzen sowohl Serbien als auf als
auch Kossovo sind dabei massiv
aufzurüsten Kosovo mit Unterstützung der
Amerikaner und der Türkei ist dabei eine
eigenständige Armee aufzubauen zieljah
ist
2028 aber auch Serbien rüstet auf
kauft momentan massiv Waffensysteme
Flugabwehr und so weiter in China
und diskutiert die Wiedereinführung der
er whrpflicht liegt also im Trend dessen
was wir vorhin auch gehört
haben
bosnienherzegowiina dazu wäre viel zu
sagen aber lange Rede kurzer Sinn der
deltenprozess ist seit einigen Jahren
völlig zusammengebrochen die Serben
haben sich aus den gemeinsamen
Institutionen zurückgezogen und
die bosnischen Serben verfolgen se
zessionspläne sehr
entschieden und das unter den Augen der
internationalen Gemeinschaft und es
bringt mich zu meinem dritten Punkt
nämlich der Handlungsweise und den
Handlungsmöglichkeiten der sogenannten
Staatengemeinschaft sowohl in Bosnien
als auch im Kosovo sind die eigentlichen
Konfliktursachen im Krieg nicht
beseitigt worden und im Frieden nicht
überwunden worden
beide Kriege der in Bosnien und der im
Kosovo sind ohne klare Sieger und
Verlierer zu Ende gegangen das bedeutet
dass die ehemaligen Konfliktparteien
diesen Konflikt oder diese Konflikte
irgendwie immer noch als offen
betrachten im Kosovo geht's ja um die
Frage des Status also darf Kosovo ein
souveräner Staat sein oder nicht was
Serbien bestreitet unterstützt von
Russland und einigen anderen in Bosnien
geht's eher um den inneren Aufbau und um
die Frage wer der drei staatsvölker dort
welches der drei staatsvölker dort das
Sagen hat alle beiden Fragen sind wenn
Sie so wollen eingefroren obwohl
eingefroren die Sache gar nicht so gut
trifft denn die Lage hat sich dynamisch
verändert in den letzten Jahren und zwar
zum Schlechteren für Bosnien haben wir
eigentlich
keinerlei Strategie wie diese Blockade
des des datonvertrages überwunden werden
kann es gibt viele Vorschläge aber
keiner der irgendwie
konsensfähig wäre während im Kosovo
einer meinesachtens recht brauchbarer
Vorschlag auf dem Tisch legt den die
Europäische Union vorgelegt hat der zu
einer Normalisierung des Verhältnisses
zwischen Serbien und Kosovo führen
könnte und der dieser Vorschlag geht von
der Idee einer de facto Anerkennung
Kosovos durch Serbien aus im
staatsrechtlichen Sinne nicht im
völkerrechtlichen Sinne mit allem was
ähm dran hängt darauf haben sich die
beiden Seiten im letzten Jahr auch
grundsätzlich geeinigt allerdings ohne
dann dass zur Umsetzung notwendige
Abkommen zu schließen auch konkrete
Verhandlungen über die Rechte der Serben
verliefen im Sande so dass dieser dieses
schöne Abkommen im im Moment ähm zwar im
Raum steht aber wenig
Realisierungsmöglichkeiten hat und das
hat damit zu tun dass wir in beiden
Ländern Regierungen an der Macht haben
die die Konflikte zur populistischen
Mobilisierung benutzen und somit auch
wenig mm Bereitschaft
zeigen Konflikt beruhigend oder
vielleicht sogar auf eine Lösung
hinzuwererkden ja vielen Dank für den
Überblick das interessiert uns natürlich
brennend weil es wirklich ums Eck ist de
facto Serbien ein kleines Land was ist
denn die Motivation oder was sind die
Interessen warum kauft sich China dort
ein China folgt diese Strategie der
neuen Seidenstraße dies betrifft nicht
nur den westlichen Balkan sondern das
ist ein globales Projekt das sich von
Asien Zentralasien über den Balkan bis
hin nach Afrika und sogar Lateinamerika
zieht also das darf man nicht als
rein sousagen als eine balkanstrategie
missverstehen sondern eine der globalen
Einflussnahme die in als
wirtschaftliches Projekt daherkommt
Finanzierung von
Infrastruktur und äh über Kredite aber
de facto natürlich darauf abzielt
längerfristig auch politische
Abhängigkeiten herzustellen das muss
einen auch ziemlich klar sein vielen
Dank wie es weitergeht hören wir dann in
der zweiten Runde wir schauen nach
Afrika ich komme zu Frau Witz sie haben
länger dort auch gelebt und Afrika ist
bei uns nicht immer in den Schlagzeilen
dennoch gibt es viele Konfliktherde oder
Krisenregionen die auch für Österreich
relevant sind können sie uns da bitte
einen Überblick geben ja Frau Ministerin
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren ähm ich
muss meinen Rückblick auf 2023 be einen
ganzen Kontinent machen mit 55 Staaten
insofern kann das nur sehr
holzschnittartig
sein ich werde drei großtendenzen sagen
aufzeigen und genau ein paar Beispiele
jeweils
nennen die erste großtendenz ist leider
dass auch für den afrikanischen konent
die Rückschau auf 2023
eine ja negative ist nämlich wir haben
es auch auf dem afrikanischen Kontinent
mit einer Zunahme der politischen Gewalt
zu tun wieder einmal
auch in diesem Jahr
wir sehen insbesondere eine Zunahme an
Gewalt die durch
staatliche Armeen ausgeübt wird im
eigenen Land und nach wie vor sehr sehr
hohe Raten von Gewalt gegen
Zivilistinnen die eben als primäre Opfer
der dieser zunehmenden Gewalt zu sehen
ist ich möchte ein auf ein paar
sozusagen der primären Krisen her
Hinweisen sehr bekannt tatsächlich ja
auch hier sind die
sahelstaaten bukina Somali Niger
mittlerweile seit dem Juli 23 alle drei
Staaten von Militär runtas regiert in
allen drei Staaten sehen wir die
Expansion geographisch aber auch
andersweitig Expansion jihadistischer
Akteure die auf die eine oder andere
Weise versuchen die staatliche Ordnung
herauszu fordern und sich eben
tatsächlich regional ausgebreitet haben
diese regionale Ausbreitung geht
mittlerweile bis in die nördlichen
Gebiete der westafrikanischen
Küstenstaaten quivoir Benin TOGU mit der
Tendenz eben sich auch weiterhin
auszubreiten seit 2012 seit Beginn der
Krise sehen wir eine Zunahme eben der
Gewalt Ende 2023 das letzte Quartal war
das gewaltvollste in diesen Ländern seit
Beginn der Krise 2012 das heißt die
Militärregierung in den Ländern sind
alle mit dem Anspruch angetreten
besonders eben der Sicherheitslage her
zu werden das war die große Vorwurf an
die Vorgängerregierungen die geputscht
wurden und in allen drei Ländern können
wir sagen das zeigt sich nicht keine der
Regierung hat es geschafft dieser
sicherheitspolitischen Herausforderung
dieser Gewalt irgendwie her zu werden
und natürlich haben es auch die enormen
internationalen Interventionen die wir
seit 2012 in dieser Region sehen nicht
geschafft
dort eine adäquate Antwort zu biieben
das wäre die Sahelzone
ein ein vermutlich hier etwas
vergessener Konflikt ist der im Sudan
der 2023 noch weiter eskaliert ist mit
großem eskalations weiteren
Eskalationspotenzial seit April haben
wir haben wir es hier mit dem internen
ähm Krieg zwischen einer ähm ehemaligen
Miliz und der Armee zu tun insgesamt 6
Millionen sudanesinnen sind intern
vertrieben in ihrem eigenen Land die
Hälfte der Bevölkerung ist aktuell auf
humanitäre ähm Hilfe angewiesen alle
friedensverhandlungsversuche sind
alleine schon daran gescheitert dass
beide Konfliktparteien keinerlei
Interesse tatsächlich zeigen zu einer
irgendeiner Form von Verhandlungslösung
hier zu
kommen letztes Beispiel m was zunächst
2022 als ein hoffnungsfall galt
Äthiopien 2022 gab es in Friedensschluss
zwischen den Separatisten aus tigrei der
Nordregion und der Zentralregierung das
international tatsächlich sehr gefeiert
wurde auch als Beispiel fürusagen auch
international gefördertes
friedensengagement hier sehen wir dass
dieser Friedensschluss dazu geführt hat
dass die Gewalt an anderen Landesteilen
ausgebrochen ist sich also andere
gewaltakteure dieses Potenzials von
friedensverhandlung sozusagen bedienen
und das das äthiopische Regime zunehmend
repressiv vorgeht nicht nur innerhalb
des Landes sondern eben auch nach außen
hin sich zunehmend versucht eventuell
eben auch mit Gewalt Zugang zum Roten
Meer zu verschaffen das heißt das hat
Eskalationspotenzial für die gesamte
Region
es bleiben die großen konfliktde Somalia
es bleibt der Krieg im im Osten Kongos
wie gesagt ich kann das nur kurz
andeuten ich möchte noch auf zwei andere
grundlegende sagen Entwicklungen
hinweisen die relevant sind das eine ist
dass wir es mit einer grundlegenden und
sehr tiefgreifenden autokratisierung zu
tun haben auf dem Kontinent für die
nicht nur die drei Putsche die ich
bereits erwähnt habe stehen sondern auch
Entwicklung in anderen Staaten z.B eben
Äthiopien was wir also sehen ist eine
zunehmende Konsolidierung autokratischer
Regime und und zwar vor allen Dingen
solche die schon akute Gewaltkonflikte
haben und das hat natürlich folgen dafür
wie wir in der Zukunft ähm zu erwarten
haben wie mit diesen Gewaltkonflikten
umgegangen wird das heißt dieser
autokratische Konsolidierung ist
tatsächlich eine neue Realität ähm die
selbst wenn es sag Ankündigung für
Wahlen gibt vermutlich auch in den
nächsten Jahren sich nicht ähm verändern
wird und die vor allen Dingen dazu führt
dass akute Gewaltkonflikte sehr
wahrscheinlich weiterhin eben eher mit
physisch Gewalt und gegenewalt denn mit
Verhandlung beendet werden die dritte
grundlegende Entwicklung auf die ich
hinweisen möchte ist die zunehmende
Diversifizierung oder Multiplizierung
der Akteure der sicherheitsakteure auf
dem Kontinent und zwar haben wir es hier
tatsächlich mit einer sehr grundlegenden
Transformation dessen zu tun wer
eigentlich für Frieden und Sicherheit
auf dem afrikanischen Kontinent sorgt
2023 war das Ende von zwei großen
UN-Missionen die UN-Mission in Mali
minusma und die Mission in der ähm in in
der Demokratischen Republik Kongo beide
beendet auf Wunsch des gastgebenden
Landes wir haben es hier mit sehr
grundlegendem Herausforderung für diese
Art von internationalem Krisenmanagement
oder Friedens Bemühungen zu tun die also
angesichts der akuten Gewalt
kein adäquates Mittel mehr bieten und
die keine politische Unterstützung mehr
in dieser Form ähm auf dem Kontinent
bekommen gleichzeitig mit dem ähm mit
dem Ende der oder mit dem endgültigen
auch Abzug der französischen
Streitkräfte aus Niger sehen wir auch
dassusagen das alte postkoloniale die
postkolonialen
Machtsphären auch die
sind zu Ende auf der anderen Seite sehen
wir das Erstarken neuer
sicherheitsakteure das heißt neue
sicherheitspartnerschaften unter anderem
eben der sahelstaaten mit Russland mit
China aber eben auch mit der Türkei dem
Iran den Emiraten das heißt also hier äh
eine sehr sehr breite Diversifizierung
sagen dessen wer eigentlich Interesse
und auch aktiv eben an Sicherheit und
Sicherheitspolitik auf dem Kontinent
beteiligt ist das hat zwei Konsequenzen
einmal ist sozusagen die Multiplizierung
der Akteure bedeutet dass in Zukunft
für diese akuten Gewaltkonflikte
international gemeinsame Lösung zu
finden oder eine gemeinsame
Unterstützung für diese Konflikte ähm
wird immer schwerer weil wir es mit sehr
sehr vielen sehr sehr unterschiedlich
interessierten ähm internationalen
Akteuren zu tun haben gleichzeitig sind
diese neuen Akteure das kann man nicht
von der Hand weisen primär nicht
liberale Staaten auch da lässt sich
erwarten dass in zukunftag
internationale Unterstützung für
friedensverhandlung etwa immer schwerer
werden sich da also auf gemeinsame
Normen und eben gemeinsame Ziele zu zu
konzentrieren vor allen Dingen eben was
die äh dannag grundsätzliche äh
Bearbeitung der strukturellen
Konfliktursachen angeht ja super vielen
Dank für den Überblick wir sind schon
gespannt welche Auswirkung das auch für
Europa und für Österreich im konkreten
hat wir schauen jetzt nach Israel und
Gaza der 710 kam für viele Menschen
überraschend aber Herr bnett für sie
nicht na ja das muss ich jetzt doppelt
beantworten also grundsätzlich hat
mirich das 7 ZTE nicht überrascht und
lassen sie m dann ausführen warum außer
vielleicht von der Monstrosität wie der
Bundespräsident Fischer gesagt hat diese
Monstrosität des Krieges am 7 Oktober
und se her obwohl es e nicht
überraschend ist wenn man das Buch von
Herf Münkler über den 30jährigen Krieg
gelesen hat das er vor Paen publiziert
hat wir mir das sie sowohl im
Einleitungskapitel als auch im
abschlussskapitel sehr stark mit der
Frage welche Parallelen zwischen dem
30jährigen Krieg und den derzeitigen
Kriegen im nah Mittleren Osten
stattfinden da war Gas noch nicht so im
Vordergrund am 7 Oktober selbst war ich
ein wenig überrascht ich darf mit einer
kurzen Anekdote beginnen es war ein
wunderschöner Tag Samstag ich befand
mich am ostwärtigen Ufer des Toten
Meeres
mit Blick hinüber und auf das Meer mein
Freund Stefan Riner der bei reinweit
hinten sitzt wir haben uns überlegt ob
wir am nächsten Wochen in dem Auftrag
des Generalsekretärs hinüberfahren in
die Westbank um dort den Leiter des
koordinationsbüros der Österreich
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit Christoph
Sterner zu treffen das ist im vorher da
nicht gelungen weil gerade wie wir
rüberfahren wollten haben die Isis
wieder mal die Grenze dicht gemacht
wegen eines kurzen Konfliktes in der
Westbank und während wir es ü Tote Meer
schauen sehen wir immer mehr kondensp
auf der anderen Seite des ufas die
eindeutig nicht von Verkehrsflugzeugen
gestammt haben sondern vermutlich von
F16 od F35 und spaßber sag noch na die
israelische Luftwaffe muss aber sehr
viel mehr dienstleistungsstunden haben
dass da am Schabat so intensiv fliegen
können und dieser Spaß ist uns dann
leider in der Kehle stecken geblieben
als wir gleich darauf nachgeschaut haben
was denn der Grund ist und das war
natürlich der Angriff des 7 Oktobers und
alles was sei in dieser monströsen Art
passiert ist lässt einen diese Anekdote
natürlich ein Biss das Betrachten als in
diesem Moment damals die Vorgeschichte
und
beginne nicht bei 1866 und dem
österreichischen Wiener Burschenschafter
Theod Herzel und seinem Buch über den
Judenstaat ist der Beginn der
zionistischen Idee und nicht mal bei
1948 sondern nur ganz kurz in den Jahren
davor die Jahre davor so spätestens ab
20 haben eine gewisse trügerische
Ruhe vermittelt im nanomittleren Osten
die den nationalen Sicherheit Berater
der USA Jack Sullivan am 8 Tage vor dem
7 Oktober dazu hinreien lassen zu sagen
dass D nahosten eigentlich friedlicher
ist als in den letzten 20 Jahren davor
die Gründe für diese Einschätzung waren
sicher viele es war die Annäherung
Saudi-Arabien lange Jahre durch human
Betrieben am Schluss durch China erwirkt
zu Beginn des Jahres 23 im März es waren
die seit Jahren versuche einige
arabische Staaten mit Israel zu
befrieden einzuhegen und eine
Wirtschaftsgemeinschaft zu bilden hinter
diesem Begriff der Abrahams Accord also
federführen dabei die vereinigten
arabischen erate bachrein Marokko
witzigerweise ad Sudan der damit
versucht hat von der Terrorliste nach
2019 zu
kommen es waren die Gespräche
Saudi-Arabien Israel sehr stark von den
USA gedränkt wenige
Tage vor dem 7 Oktober es so als könnte
es zu einem Abschluss kommen da ist es
um den hohen Ölpreis gegangen aber auch
um andere Fragen es waren Ereignisse da
vor wie die Grenzziehung die
seegrenzziehung zwischen dem Libanon und
Israel nach vielen vielen
Jahrzehnten auch mit dem Hintergrund
dass die vielen Gasvorkommen die da im
östlichen Mittelmeer sich befinden von
Ägypten die ganze Küste hinlang bis
südlich von Zypern die Staaten an diese
Gasfelder anzuschließen ein schließlich
des Libanons was zu dem Zeitpunkt ganz
positiv ausgesehen hat aber auch
Leitungen zu bauen gasverteilersysteme
Flüsse
verflüssigungsanlagen Syrien
anzuschließen Syrien das erst im
Mai
23 wieder in die arabische oder Oktober
muss jetzt aufassen mai 23 in die
Arabische Liga zurückgekehrt ist nachdem
es seit 2011 durch den Bürgerkrieg
ausgeschlossen war das alles hat darauf
hingedeutet dass es irgendwie zu
Beruhigung kommen könnte meine
Mitarbeiterin und ich schreiben seit
2019 durchgehend dass wir das nicht
glauben dass wir glauben dass das alles
eben nur so eine trügerische Illusion
ist weil sie quasi auf dem Rücken des
palästinensischen Volkes stattfindet es
ist eine Einigung von reichen mächtigen
stärkeren Staaten
die das was die Palästinenser schon
immer anstreben also jetzt nicht die
Vertreibung der Israel und 1948
rückgäemchen das ist ja spätestens seit
dem Brief von Jasi Arafat 1989
an den israelischen Staatspräsidenten
Geschichte bis auf wenige
äh aber das ihnen des was mE als zwei
staatenlösung sehr lange schon im Mund
hat dass das eigentlich eine dass das
unrealistisch geworden ist
und die Angst vieler Palästinenser vor
allem im Jahr 22 war es dass es eine
solche Einigung auf ihrem Rücken geben
wird dass es am Schluss eine Umsetzung
vielleicht des trumpans oder einer
ähentlichen Konfiguration geben wird äh
und es war viele natürlich vor allem für
die
radikalisierten keine Option es ist aber
auch für die nicht radikalisierten am
Schluss keine Option und es ist der
Grund warum die radikalisierten sich
halt gegen die breite Masse durchsetzen
konnte was vielleicht ein kleines Indiz
auch hätte sein können es ist von vielen
belächelt worden im August 20 gibt's
einen dreitage Krieg zwischen dem
palästinensischen Jihad aus Gaza heraus
und Israel mit der paar
Raketenangriffen die darin münden dass
die Hamas die oberhter des
palestinensischen jihadi die für diese
Angriffe auf Israel verantwortlich
worden den Israelis gedanklich
ausliefert die die eliminieren können
und danach sagt die Hamas und andere zum
palästinensischen dihad jetzt ist noch
nicht die Zeit für den Angriff der große
Angriff kommt ein anderes Mal und seit
diesem Zeitpunkt wird scheinbar diese
als Achse des Widerstands bezeichnet
oder schitischer Halbmond oder wie Ring
of Fire wie dieel ist dazu sagen sei
wird diese Achse aus Iran
unterschiedlichsten sunnitischen und
schitischen aufstandsgruppen im ganzen
Raum
immer härter und dichter und zu einer
echten Gefahr für Israel und ausgelöst
wurde es dann am 7 Oktober der jetzige
Stand ist den meisten sicher bekannt sie
beobachten das in Film und Funk der
Flächenbrand könnte das nächste
eintrittende Ereignis sein wieer
ausschaut glaube ich können man uns
vielleicht nachher bisschen unterhalten
aber es sind ja heute schon einige
Punkte gesprochen worden also
insbesondere auch die Involvierung der
weltwirtschaftsfrage durch die meeräe
bei babelmandab hinau das Rote Meer bis
in den suiskanal und wie uns das
betrifft wurde ja schon angesprochen und
das ist halt Teil dieser Geschichte des
Flächenbrandes nämlich die Frage wie
viele andere sonstige bewaffnete
Konflikte im Umfeld können dadurch
wieder angeheizt werden bis zu welcher
Intensität oder gibt's davor irgendeine
Form von
Einhegung ich glaube eines der Ziele
dürfte sein die amerik in großen Teilen
aus dem Raum zu verdrängen weil es ja
sowas wie Vakuum nicht gibt wer weggeht
s geshen in Westafrika wen die
Europäische Union geht wer weggeht wird
durch jemanden anderen ersetzt und es
ist der oder diejenige die dann bestimmt
was im Raum passiert vielen Dank herrnet
Herr hofbau sie sind Militärstratege wir
haben jetzt die Einschätzung der
Expertinnen zu den Konfliktregionen
gehört was sind denn ihre Einschätzungen
ja danke schön die Ausgangslage ist wie
wir gehört haben überschauar gut ich
würde sagen eher unangenehm und für uns
als Streitkräfte Planer und
langfristigge Entwickler von Fähigkeiten
ist es natürlich eine massive
Herausforderung der Ausgangslage ist
aber nicht an dem zu messen was wir
gerade jetzt in den Medien lesen sondern
wir würden doch mal gerne die letzten
zwei Jahre hernehmen um zu sehen was
sich da alles entwickeln kann und wie
rasch das von von statten gegangen ist
welche neuen Herausforderungen sich mit
den alten verbunden haben und welche
alten Herausforderungen wir alle nicht
mehr sehen weil sie dur die derzeitige
Situation überdeckt sind
Europa hat aufgehört sich in den letzten
25 Jahren auf den Krieg zu
vorzubereiten es ist ein massiver
Unterschied ob wir Streitkräfte auf
einen Kriegseinsatz oder auf
stabilisierungseinsätze vorbereiten ich
komme dann in weiterer Folge auf das
noch zu sprechen wir haben natürlich
nicht die Kristallkugel um hervorzusehen
was denn da auf uns zukommen wird wo
wird der nächste Krieg geführt wer führt
ih warum und mit wem nur eines ist aus
meiner Sicht klar es wird schneller und
es wird
mehr
die aktuellen Herausforderung vor der
wir stehen ist das zukünftige
einsatzumfeld möglichst
einzu hegen und einen Begriff davon zu
entwickeln wie was da auf uns zukommt
und wir müssen sehen dass im Endeffekt
die bereits durch den General klar
definierten Begrifflichkeiten wie der
Kampf in der Grauzone etwas sind mit dem
wir uns auseinandersetzen müssen wir
sind in einer Phase wo
das allgemeine Wertesystem amtzerbrechen
ist die grundsätzlichen Werte und auch
die Rechtsnormen in Frage gestellt
werden und wir somit nicht in einer
Phase zwischen Krieg und Frieden
unterscheiden können sondern wir sind in
einer Phase derzeit auch in Europa und
auch in Österreich logischerweise mit
davon betroffen wo es noch nicht Krieg
aber auch nicht mehr reiner Frieden ist
wir haben die nichtstaatlichen Akteure
die in dieser Grauzone dazu eingesetzt
werden das staatliche Gewaltmonopol zu
unterlaufen vollendete Tatsachen zu zu
zu setzen das sehen wir in Afrika wir
sehen das aber auch in der Ukraine und
auch in anderen Konflikten hinzukommen
zu den herkömmlichen Fragestellungen des
konventionell militärischen wenn wir es
mal oberflächlich so definieren die
ganzen neuen Dimensionen die auch ganz
schlecht und ganz wenig rechtlich
geregelt sind ganz anders als im
Kriegsvölkerrecht wie z.B die cyberers
gesamte Cyberspace der Weltraum kaum
reglementiert und natürlich das
informationsumfeld und das ist
militärisch singulär nicht
bewältigbar wir wir reden seit Jahren
über den comprehensive approach das ist
auch sehr stark über die internationalen
Einsätze gekommen jetzt gilt's aber das
wirklich umzusetzen we jetzt GT's
wirklich es GT nicht darum mehr primär
in
stabilisierungseinsätzen in einem Land
far away und und wahrscheinlich auch
nicht so im Fokus der politischen und
der und der Bevölkerung in den in den
Staaten die Soldaten D hinen
senden neue Rechtsformen aufzustellen
sondern es geht jetzt darum die Nationen
in Europa wieder verteidigungsfähig zu
machen und da ist natürlich das nicht
nur über die militärische Schiene allein
bewältigbar wir haben es bereits gehört
über die Frage der Wirtschaft die
verbundesministerin hat angesprochen die
geistige Landesverteidigung warum geht
es überhaupt um welche Werte kämpfen wir
wo ist es notwendig und richtig
überhaupt ins Gefecht zu ziehen und
natürlich müssen wir auch noch mit
berücksichtigen einen wesentlichen
Aspekt nämlich die unn unnowns nämlich
alles das was da am Horizont herankommt
wo wir noch nicht genau sehen wie es
sich auswirken wird alles in
Zusammenhang mit artificial intelligence
aber auch mit den biologischen Waffen ö
ist nicht ist nicht notwendigerweise
hier losgelöst zu sehen wir können uns
nicht im Zentrum Europas für sicher
einschätzen natürlich sind wir kein
Frontstaat wir sind aber jedenfalls auch
nicht davor gefeitt sollte es im Osten
oder im Südosten wir haben da sehr viele
Eindrücke jetzt gerade bekommen von dem
was in Europa alles vor sich geht oder
was der Ring of Fire rund um
Österreich auswirken kann oder an Folgen
nach sich ziehen kann wir sind mit
Aktivitäten konfrontiert Verrat Spionage
Subversion nur um eines zu nennen
ausspeung das ist etwas was ständig
läuft die narrative die gegen die
westliche Wertegemeinschaft hochgezogen
werden
und die Einflussnahme von außen die
Ukraine und der Krieg in der Ukraine
sollten uns aber nicht verführen nur das
als die Zukunft zu sehen bei weiten
nicht wir sehen einen Konflikt wie
vielleicht sich weiterentwickeln kann
nur wenn wir 10 15 Jahre vorausdenken
wird die Ukraine nur einer von vielen
Konflikten und Kriegen sein die im
Endeffekt ein schlaglich darauf legen wo
das zukünftige Konflikt hingeht und wir
sollten vor allem eines
machen in der Beurteilung schärfer
werden wir lassen uns verführen von dem
dass wir vielleicht keine politischen
Absichten erkennen wir haben aber
vergessen die Potenziale zu beurteilen
und die Potenziale sind langfristig
aufgebaut und sind langfristig vorhanden
politische Absichten Potenziale
einzusetzen können sich sehr kurzfristig
ändern und wie wir gesehen haben es ist
so angesprochen worden die zehnjährige
vorwahzeit das ist wirklich Geschichte
und vor allem wir haben nicht gesagt die
10 Jahre beginnen jetzt zu laufen und
aus meiner Sicht war 2014 spätestens der
Zeitpunkt wo wir in Europa hätten
reagieren müssen zum Abschluss würde ich
ganz gerne festhalten dass wir aus
meiner Sicht in einer neuen Logik sind
die verbunden ist mit einer alten Logik
nämlich mit der Logik des Kalten Krieges
es sind ganz viele Dinge wieder
entstanden wie mutual Assur destruction
die Frage der Nuklearwaffen die
plötzlich wieder am Tisch liegen die wir
mitdenken müssen die wir über 30 Jahre
aber mehr oder weniger abgelegt
haben es geht um die weaponization of
everything alles wird dazu genutzt um
offensiv Einfluss zu nehmen und
Interessen durchzusetzen und das ist
viel stärker die Ausprägung in den
autokratischen Systemen und sehr
schwierig für westlich demokratischees
System dagegen zu halten und das wirkt
sich natürlich auch auf das Militär aus
dass hier eine Aufgabe zu erfüllen hat
vielen Dank Herr Hofbauer kommen wir zur
zweiten frageerunde und es geht
natürlich um 2024 und wie geht's weiter
das ist natürlich super spannend
Professor mangott was ist ihre
Einschätzung wie geht Russland Ukraine
der Krieg weiter Russland Russland ist
in der Lage diesen Krieg lange zu führen
auch ihn zu finanzieren bitte Mikro
Einschalten von Professor mangott noch
einmal n Russland ist in der Lage diesen
Krieg noch lange zu finanzieren auch
militärisch auszurüsten russland hat
also nicht jetzt Zeit Not auch die
innenpolitische Stabilität ist soweit
gewährleistet durch massive Repression
dass dieser Krieg weitergeführt werden
kann wir werden im März die Krönung von
Vladimir Putin zum Präsidenten Russland
sehen in einer natürlich nicht freien
und fairen Wahl wesentliches ist wie
geht es mit Finanz und Militärhilfe
weiter da werden wir sehen beim
Europäischen Rat jetzt ob hier ein
Kompromiss zu erzielen ist wir werden
beobachten müssen wie sich dieser
verhandlungs äh Druck in den USA
entwickelt ob die Republikaner
eingeschworen werden können auf dieses
von beiden Mitte Oktober des letzten
Jahres beantragten
unterstützungspaketes Finanz und
Militärhilfe von 61,4 Milliarden wenn
das nicht so kommt oder vielleicht auch
gar nicht kommt dann ist das sicherlich
etwas was
kriegsmitentscheidend sein wird keine
Frage für die Republikaner ist es
natürlich so dass die republikanischen
Wähler und WählerInnen derzeit mit
76% glauben dass die USA schon zu viel
zur Unterstützung der Ukraine
beigetragen haben und angesichts der
bevorstehenden Präsidentenwahlen und der
Kongresswahlen ist das natürlich ein ein
Faktor den die republikanische Partei äh
berücksichtigt muss und das bringt mich
schon auch dazu ganz essentiell wird die
Entscheidung am 5 November sein in den
USA die
Präsidentenwahlen die dort stattfinden
kriegsmütigkeit dürfte wachsen auch im
Westen dürfte sie wachsen Unterstützung
der Ukraine wird auch zunehmend zum
Thema werden im Sinne von
verteilungskonkurrenz
Verteilungskonflikten wofür sind
staatliche Ausgaben da für die
Heimatfront gewissermaßen oder für die
Front weiter im Osten ich möchte nur
eins sagen
das vielleicht sehr kontrovers ist es
wird in der westlichen Diskussion nicht
nur in der politischen sondern auch in
der wissenschaftlichen immer wieder
gesagt Europa verteidigt verzeihen Sie
Ukraine verteidigt die Sicherheit
Europas meine Position ist das gilt nur
dann wenn wir sagen unser Ziel ist dass
die Ukraine möglichst lange und intensiv
gegen die russische Armee kämpft damit
Russland mittelfristig vielleicht sogar
langfristig militärisch geschwächt ist
wenn das unser Ziel in diesem Krieg ist
dann verteidigt die Ukraine Europas
Sicherheit aber sonst verteidigt sie
sich nur selbst zurecht und gemäß dem
Völkerrecht sie verteidigt ihre
territoriale Integrität und ihre
Unversehrtheit aber es ist nicht so was
jetzt im politischen Diskurs und leider
auch unterstützt von vielen Experten
gesagt wird wenn die Ukraine diesen
Krieg verliert dann steht der Ivan
gewissermaßen in Riga und in Talin oder
gar in Warschau ich glaube es gibt
imperiale Ambitionen bei Personen wie
Putin batruschew bortnikov wie sie alle
heißen aber Ambitionen sind das eine und
Fähigkeit sind das andere und wir können
nicht gleichzeitig argumentieren dass
die qualifiziertesten russischen
Einheiten schon aufgerieben worden sind
in der Ukraine und dann sagen dann aber
wenn der ukrainekrieg fertig sein wird
wissen nicht wie dann wird es gegen
Europa gehen ich glaube das ist ein ein
politisch gewollter Diskurs der die
Kriegsmüdigkeit in westlichen
Gesellschaften Bremsen soll aber er hat
eigentlich keine reale Grundlage
trotzdem NATO stadfast Defender ist ein
wichtiges notwendiges Manöver Bündnis
müssen sich auf alle contingencies
vorbereiten auch auf unwahrscheinliche
und es gilt nicht nur eben die die
übungsfähigkeit zu demonstrieren sondern
echt die abschreckungsfähigkeit
aufzubauen und ich kann nicht zustimmen
denen die sagen dieses natomanöver sei
eskalativ denn zur Eskalation hat
natürlich im Wesentlichen Russland
beigetragen was bedeutet denn die
Fortschreitung des Krieges für
Österreich
konkret und wenn ich noch da für Europa
bedeutet dieser Krieg und es wird auch
weiter so gehen eine
Stärke und deutliche Abhängigkeit von
den Vereinigten Staaten Europa hat
gezeigt wieder einmal dass es sich nicht
verteidigen kann vielleicht bei manchen
sich auch nicht verteidigen will die USA
sind das sicherheitsgarant für Europa
unabdingbar notwendig wie immer das sich
auch entwickeln könnte nach einem
wahlseg Donald Trumps und die USA lassen
sich das natürlich etwas kosten die
machen das ja nicht nur aus Altruismus
und ich denke wo Europa das besonders
spüren wird ist in der euchina Politik
dass die USA nämlich von der EU im
Gegenzug fordern ih China Politik mit
jener der Politik der der USA zu
synchronisieren dazu kurz für Österreich
bedeutet das das gleiche was ich für die
NATO gesagt habe ist man kann die
Neutralität weiter unterstützen aber
nicht den Mythos dass die Neutralität
uns vor Krieg stützt wenn dann muss es
eine whrfähige eine bewaffnende
bewaffnete und
verteidigungsfähige Neutralität sein
auch eine aktive politische Neutralität
und das braucht die Finanzmittel die
langsam ins Fließen kommen um diese
werrfähigkeit auch aufzubauen und das
sind wir wieder beim Thema vorbereiten
vorbereiten vorbereiten vielen Dank Herr
Professor Frau Professor am Balkan sie
haben es angesprochen dieses
konfliktdreieck wie sie es beschrieben
haben die Spannungen wie wie
ernstzunehmen sind diese Spannungen
können Sie exploodtieren was sind denn
ihre Einschätzungen wie geht's 2024
weiter die Kombination aus
eingefrorenen oder immer noch
vorhandenem Konflikt und populistischen
Führungen in der gesamt Region deutet
drauf hin dass die Konflikte und
Spannungen andauern werden wir müssen
erneut weiterhin mit lokalen auch
gewaltsamen Ausschreitungen
rechnen was meines Erachtens nicht im
Raum steht ist ein großer Krieg also ein
Einmarsch Serbiens in die eine oder
andere
Richtung keiner der Akteure vor Ort hat
im Moment Interesse dran einen solchen
großen Krieg zu führen insbesondere auch
Serbien nicht dass ja mit der
Europäischen Union verhandelt das hat
einen
immens pazifizierenden Effekt obwohl
sich wuic ja so verhält als sei er in
alle Richtungen und für alle Optionen
offen ich bin überzeugt wenn es har hart
kommt ist die europäische Option die
bevorzugte die Parteien haben im Moment
auch gar nicht die militärischen Mittel
für einen großen Konflikt ich habe
gesagt die sind dabei aufzurüsten aber
Moment
sind sie nicht s weit wie das in ein
paar Jahren aussieht steht auf einem
anderen Blatt und wie sich die
Interessenlage bis dahin noch verändern
wird auch man könnte sicher auch
durchaus vorstellen dass für die
kosowaren der Krieg wieder eine Option
wird wenn sie stark genug wären z.B
einen Angriff auf
nordmetroviza zu führen da hat's in der
äh früheren und in der jüngsten
Geschichte auch Beispiele gegeben dass
ähm eine in Anführungszeichen ethnische
Säuberung durchaus zum Erfolg führen
könnte und dann werden natürlich die
Karten auch neu gemischt ich denke aber
das ist jetzt nicht für 20 24 ähm auf
dem Plan die
ähm Friedenstruppen vor Ort die
peacekeepers NATO KF haben eine immens
wichtige Funktion ähm die sind natürlich
als sterrat zu verstehen und haben eine
abschreckende Wirkung deswegen ist ist
auch wichtig dass diese Vorort bleiben
darüber hinaus sollte man aber nicht
vergessen dass die politische Option
weiter zu verfolgen ist die stecken
Moment wie ich sagte in der Sackgasse
die letzte Rettung ist ja immer die EU
gewesen aber der paspatu EU-Erweiterung
funktioniert im Moment nicht und auch
schon lange nicht aus zwei Gründen weil
die EU nicht einig ist wir haben da
Länder die eine Sonderrolle spielen
insbesondere
Ungarn dass äh sich da eng mit den
bosnischen Serben und mit wuic verbündet
und letztlich auch immer dazu geführt
hat dass die EU mit einer Stimme
sprechen kann z.B um Sanktionen gegen
die bosnischen Serben zu verhängen so
wie das die USA schon gemacht haben also
es wäre auf jeden Fall wichtig da wo man
Einfluss hat auch Einfluss auszuüben um
Einigkeit in der EU herzustellen und das
zweite Thema ist natürlich das Thema
südosterweiterung das seine positiven
Anreizwirkung verloren hat einfach weil
sich die EU mittlerweile so das so lange
auf die lange Bank geschoben hat dass
auch die gutwilligsten in der Regionen
eigentlich den Optimismus verloren haben
dass das bei Zeiten zu einer
Fortschreiten in Richtung EU kommen kann
und um noch eins drauf zusetzen die
Tatsache dass jetzt Ukraine und noch
zwei
weitere Staaten Kandidaten geworden sind
macht ja letztlich noch
unwahrscheinlicher Aussicht der Region
denn die Ukraine aufzunehmen nicht nur
befindet die sich im Krieg sondern das
würde das ganze Gefüge der Europäischen
Union ja massiv
in Frage stellen und so wird's im Moment
ja auch diskutiert wir können nur
erweitern wenn auch nach Südosten wenn
EU sich als solche reformiert das heißt
diese beiden Fragen hängen zusammen
südosterweiterung oder überhaupt
EU-Erweiterung und EU Reform das das ist
ein sehr großes Projekt ein sehr
langfristiges Projekt und jemand dazu
Ergebnissen kommt bleiben die kleinen
Schritte also sprich peacekeeping vor
Ort Förderung der regionalen
Zusammenarbeit aber auch Lösung im
Detail Normalisierung Serbien und Kosovo
vordringliche Aufgaben vielen Dank Frau
wi Afrika sie haben es angesprochen da
gibt es viele viele Regionen was
erwarten Sie
2024 also ich denke mal zunächst ist
leider auch in einem ähnlich
pessimistischen Blick festzuhalten dass
wir es dass wir aktuell keinen größeren
nennenswerten Friedensprozess auf dem
Kontinent sehen das ist ein großer
Unterschied zu früheren Dekaden in denen
es ähnlich soagen hohe politische Gewalt
gab aber eben laufende Friedensprozesse
stattgefunden haben so ähm eingeschränkt
die vielleicht auch waren das sehen wir
nicht in vergangen Woche ist in in Mali
auch noch der das algirabkommen
aufgekündigt worden das heißt selbst die
bestehenden wie gesagt so ähm so
vielleicht auch eingeschränkt sie
tatsächlich zum Erfolg bisher geführt
hab aber ähm
auch diese Abkommen gelten nicht mehr
gerade in den sahelstaaten ist
tatsächlich die Aussicht dass wir es da
sofern sich die Regierung weiter an der
Macht halten können
weiter mit einer massiven sagen
gewaltstrategie gegen äh gegen die
gewaltakteure sehen das heißt keinerlei
sag Versuch der ähm der der anderen Art
sozusagen der der strukturellen
Konfliktbearbeitung die eigentlich eben
zumindest parallel dazu eben laufen
müsste das heißt Konfliktbearbeitung die
vor allen Dingen eben massiv die
Zivilbevölkerung betrifft das istag
grundsätzlich tatsächlich die sehr sehr
trag der sehr sehr tragische Ausblick
Moment für die großen Gewaltkonflikte
auf dem Kontinent das gleiche gilt eben
für den Sudan zwei Faktoren denke ich
sind für sagen für für das für den
Verlauf von 2024 und dann für die
Zukunft relevant das sind einmal Wahlen
19 afrikanische Staaten 19 von55 werden
2024 wählen darunter tatsächlich eben
einige Staaten mit akutem gewaltkonflikt
Südsudan potenziell Mali und Burkina
Faso aber eben auch Staaten die in Ihrer
Region jeweils eine relevante sagen
Stabilisierungsfunktion haben Südafrika
Ghana Senegal
ich sag das nicht deswegen weil ich
denke dass dass der Ausgang der
jeweiligen Wahlen relevant sein wird
sicherheitspolitisch sondern die Frage
ist welchen welche interne Sprengkraft
die Wahlen an sich haben wir haben in
gerade in dieser Region gesehen dass ähm
im Zuge von Wahlen oder nach Wahlen
besonders eben die
innenpolitische Anspannung sehr sehr
hoch ist und gerade in den drei
sahelstaaten eben dazu geführt dass das
Teile der der Militärs auf auf Wind
bekommen haben und die die Putsche
vollzogen haben das heißt die die
politische Funktion von Wahlen nicht im
Sinne von Demokratisierung sondern eben
im Sinne von sag politischer Sprengkraft
glaube ich ist extrem relevant zweiter
Punkt ist die Frage wie sich diese
Diversifizierung der der sozusagen
sicherheitspartnerschaften weiter
entwickeln wird ich hatte erwähnt die
zunehmende Rolle Rus Chinas Türkei der
Arabischen Emirate und eben der Rückzug
der in Anführungsstrichen traditionellen
Akteure inklusive eben traditioneller
Mechanismen wie UN peacekeeping hier
glaube ich wird es enorm darauf ankommen
das nicht nur als eine Entwicklung zu
sehen die sousagen stattfindet sondern
die auch aus europäischer sich zu
gestalten das heißt sich eben aktiv
dafür einzusetzen für ja unter diesen
gegebenen durchaus sehr sehr schwierigen
geopolitischen Umständen zu zu suchen
wie gerade ein un-engagement aber auch
einer EU Engagement in der Region
aussehen kann vielen vielen Dank wir
müssen ein bisschen auf die Zeit achten
Herr bnett vielleicht halten Sie sich
kurz was schätzen Sie wie Sie schätzen
Sie die den weiteren Weg von Israel und
Gaza jetzt ein also ver die mir
aufzufordern mich kurz zu halten ist
natürlich eine Herkules Aufgabe D müss
die mit an so sagen es wird e schlechter
und das scheint ja das Bild zu sein also
wenn ich zuerst den Flächenbrand
angesprochen habe dann ist das die große
Frage entsteht er wo überall rund um
Israels Syrien jemand
Libanon Irak wenn die Amerikaner
vielleicht abziehen oder zumindestens
teilweise wo wird's dadurch besser und
wo wird dadurch schlechter was wä denn
die kritische Entwicklung ihr me die
kritische Entwicklung für mich die ich
zu in dem Aufsatz den im November
geschrieben habe gesagt habe dass sie 24
mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit nicht
passieren wird die kritische Entwicklung
wäre wenn es gelingt nordjordanien
komplett zu destabilisieren wir haben
gesehen die Angriffe gestern auf die
Amerikaner waren ja in diesem
Grenzgebiet Jordanien Syrien Irak mit
einem narkostaat Syrien der ähnlich wie
Mexiko gegenüber den USA sie entwickelt
und wenn es gelingt nordjordanien zu
destabilisieren dann gibt es eine
Landverbindung zwischen dem Iran und der
Westbank und dann können dorthin
wirklich substanziell Waffen
geschmuggelt werden und dann ist es für
Israel andere Herausforderung weil dort
wohnen die Tür an Tür Haus an Haus das
ist nicht wieder gasastreffen
zniert das wird ein bisschen
herausfordernd und dann wir auch andere
die sich bis dato eigentlich nur mit ein
bisschen schirßen und ein bisschen
Verteidigung vorbereiten dann ist die
Zeit für hisbolla und
andere aktiver zu werden die Europäische
Union spielt in dem E Rolle es werden
auchch die drei Schiffe nicht dazu
beitragen die hutis die früher viele nur
für bloßfüssige bergaraberkuten haben we
auf 2000 m im Winter n Schlapfen
haben das wird die nicht beeindrucken
und insofern bin ich es gibt zwei große
Fragen die eine ist wie lang wird der
Krieg jetzt unmittelbar im Gaza dauern
da spielt die Zeit gegen Israel
letztlich und für die Hamas das wirrt
dazu führen dass die Vernichtung
deranass ich halte es für eine Illusion
im Hintergrund werden zwei Dinge
verhandelt nämlich gibt's eine
politische Lösung in der unmittelbaren
nach dem bewaffneten Konflikt
stattfindenden Phase wie kann man ein
politisches System ein palästinensisches
politisches System neu aufstellen das in
der Lage ist mit Israel was auch immer
für die Zukunft zu verhandeln das sind
vi dran beteiligt be am bekannten der
ist diesen Gesprächen ich nenne seinen
Namen jetzt nicht es ist sehr sehr
kritisch die zwei staatenlösung ich
sag's jetzt so wie ich sie sehe die ist
tot und zwar schon lang seit der I
grabin to ist seit 1995
und man wird sich ein anderes neues
politisches Modell überlegen lassen das
schwierig ist weil beide Seiten sagen
from the river to the sea egal ob das
der Bibi Netanyahu mit seiner Karte ist
die er kurz vom 7 Oktober vorgestellt
hat und genauso wie mit den radikalen
Palästinensern also solange die
radikalen auf beiden Seiten herrschen
wird's wahnsinnig schwierig werden dort
zu einem einem echten Frieden zu kommen
und bevor mein Freund Bruno hofb dran
ist schmeiß no was in Raum W bisschen
verärgert sein wird aber macht ist
natürlich die Frage wie vi
Stabilisierung wie vi Verteidigung wie
gesagt zuerst wir schon gesagt aus jedem
Raum aus dem man sich zurückzieht
steht ja kein Vakuum sondern W anderer
nimmt es
ein eine Verteidigung die an der
machtgrenze beginnt oder an der EU
Grenze ist gegenüber den Risiken die aus
dem nanoittleren Osten kommen ich sage
jetzt mal Terror Migration etc sehr
schwierig da wird zum andere Werkzeuge
gehen auch nicht
militärischen aber nur in der Reaktion
was bei den Hut ist Reaktion kann es
nicht sein wir würden in einer
Friedenslösung gefordert sein jetzt bin
aber wirklich beim letzten Satz in der
Friedenslösung gefordert sein zu
herauszufinden wie viel europäische
militärische okay vielleicht nehmen das
andere Mikro es gibt offenbar wie viel
militärische Projektion muss die
Europäische Union auch an die gegenküste
schicken wenn es irgendeine Art von
Friedenslösung im Gasastreifen gibt das
Schließen vorerst beide Seiten aus ich
würde es nie ausschließen allein das
bestehende anzumandat in dem
Österreicher der wichtige Rolle spielt
umfasst auch den Gasastreifen und es
gibt auch schon erste Ideen von
russischer Seite zumindestens
unbewaffnete Beobachter und da werden k
Anzug gefragt im Raum wirksam werden zu
lassen und das wird sie EU im nächsten
Jahr nur sehr bunt gestalten es bedarf
wirklich hohe Konzentration Herr hofbau
abschließend was bedeutet das jetzt
konkret konkret für Österreich ja was
ist was ist zu tun ich bin Nummer vier
ja sehr gut was ist zu tun ich glaub es
liegt auf der Hand es ist auch bereits
transportiert worden wir haben ein
scheidkräfteprofil als Vorgabe
umzusetzen das sieht vor dass wir uns
das Bundesheer um 180° anders
orientieren werden das schließt
natürlich alles das nicht aus
international weiterhin vor allem
eigentlich aus der hiesigen Sicht in
einer gesteigerten Qualität unds
sezubringen auf der anderen Seite aber
das Bundesheer wieder und ich sagt das
jetzt bewusst kriegsfähig zu machen das
ist jetzt ein Begriff der in aller Munde
ist aber um das geht es im Wesentlichen
es geht in der Entwicklung voran wir
brauchen Zeit Geld und Personal wie
immer und im Endeffekt haben wir eine
Zielsetzung die kriegsfähigkeit des BUND
es herzustellen und das werden wir über
vier Entwicklungslinien abarbeiten die
Kampfkraft herstellen die
Durchhaltefähigkeit die
Reaktionsfähigkeit stärken und die
führungsüberlegenheit das ist aufzubauen
um das Bundesheer zu einem
funktionierenden System zu bringen dass
sich in der Lage ist und Achtung nach
Mobilmachung den Einsatz zur
Verteidigung der Republik auch wieder
bewältigen zu können die langfristige
Dimension ist dabei zu beachten da kommt
uns zugute dass wir jetzt kein
Frontstaat sind und somit der Druck
nicht so groß ist aber er ist da die
Langfristigkeit neue Fähigkeiten ist
heute bereits angesprochen werden z.B
der Luftverteidigung aufzubauen bedeuten
mindestens 10 Jahre eine Fähigkeit zu
streichen wie wir es gemacht haben das
geht von heute auf morgen aber die Leute
sind nicht mehr da die die Expertise
haben z.B eine Fliegerabwehr wieder in
den Brigaden aufzubauen und eine
Fliegerabwehr mittlerer oder großer
reich haben wir im bundesjahr überhaupt
noch nicht gehabt da brauchen wir
Partnerschaft Kooperation das geht nur
im Verbund wo sind die Prioritäten wir
müssen sehen dass das Cyberspace das
informationsumfeld kampffelder geworden
sind wir sind mehr als ein Rechenzentrum
wir müssen im Cyberspace agieren können
wir brauchen Luftabwehr die Fähigkeit
zum Kampf und natürlich das ganze
eingebunden in die umfassende
Landesverteidigung und zum Abschluss
kann ich das nur voll unterstreichen wir
müssen uns
vorbereiten wir sind bei weiten nicht
dort wo wir hingehören und es ist klar
dass wo Militär drauf steht Militär
drinnen sein muss das erwartet sich die
Politik von uns das erwartet sich
logischerweise auch die Bevölkerung dass
wir in der Lage sind sollte es dazu
kommen dass die Verteidigung der
Republik notwendig ist wir das auch
können daher bereiten wir uns
vor
die Konflikte und Herausforderungen
werden uns in der nächsten Zeit auf
jeden Fall nicht ausgehen und ich darf
nun um die verteidigungspolitischen
Konklusionen bitten vom österreichischen
Generalsekretär dr Arnold
Kamel sehr geehrte Frau Bundesministerin
Herr Bundesminister geschätzte Herren
Abgeordnete Exzellenzen hohe Generalität
Herr
Generalanwalt ST jedes Jahr vor der
Herausforderung dass bereits alles
gesagt wurde nur nicht von jedem und das
zum anderen ihr sicherheitspolitischer
Hunger mehr und mehr vom realen Hunger
überlagert wird im Unterschied zu meinem
Mitarbeiter Günther Bnet kann ich mich
aber den noch kurz halten und möchte
Ihnen den noch drei Gedanken und drei
konkrete Ableitungen für Österreich mit
in die Mittagspause und dann auf ihren
weiteren Weg geben ein erster Gedanke
den ich mit Ihnen teilen möchte der
nicht wirklich großartig neu ist aber
der insbesondere in Österreich oftmals
unter belichtet ist wir leben seit
mehreren Jahren auf der internationalen
Bühne den realistischen Wandel einen
Wandel hin zu Realismus der die die
idealistische Vorstellung dass als Folge
der Globalisierung als Folge der
erhöhten Interdependenzen wir für
Frieden und Stabilität sichern können
dass dies nicht mehr der Realität
entspricht und wir mehr und mehr in
einer interessensgeleiteten
konfrontativen Weltlage Leben es liegt
an uns in insbesondere auch in Europa
unsere Interessen zu definieren und wenn
wir auch über das Auslandsengagement
sprechen wenn wir darüber sprechen wo
Europa auch als Akteur auftritt so
sollten wir auch hier ehrlich sein
letzten Endes geht es auch um unsere
europäischen Interessen die wir dort
auch und das Militär ist ein Instrument
dazu es gehört in den comprehensive
approach in generalmor hofbau
angesprochen hat eingebettet dass wir
diese Interessen hier auch entsprechend
verteidigen ein zweiter Punkt wir lesen
viel in diesen Zeiten von
weltunordnung multipolare Unordnung
Erosion der
Weltordnung das mag vielleicht aus
unserer westlichen Perspektive so sein
in anderen Regionen der Welt wird
vielleicht von einer notwendigen
Adjustierung des internationalen Systems
gesprochen das den Realitäten einfach
mehr entspricht ich glaube gerade wir im
Westen haben durch die Bretton Woods
Institutionen durch das internationale
System das wir aufgebaut haben auch die
Verpflichtung dieses System entsprechend
im 21 Jahrhundert weiterzuentwickeln und
auch jenen Akteuren die vielleicht
bisher nicht so im Rampenlicht waren die
nicht diesen Stellenwert hatten die mit
an Bord zu holen und gemeinsam auch die
Welt der Zukunft gestalten zu können
nehme nur das Beispiel von General ma
Hofbauer wir erleben in vielen Bereichen
oder wir stehen in vielen Bereichen vor
der Herausforderungen neue Dinge zu
reglementieren und implementieren zu
müssen wir haben aber
nicht mehr das reale Gewicht das wir als
Westen hatten um dies alleine zu tun es
liegt daher auch an uns hier gemeinsam
den outreach zu wagen zu schauen wo wir
auf gleichgelagerte Interessen stoßen um
diese Ordnung die für das Funktionieren
der Welt letzten Endes entscheidend ist
wieder entsprechend herzustellen und den
Realitäten anzupassen ein dritter
Gedanke den ich Ihnen mitgeben möchte
gerade auch das Jahr 2024 betreffend wir
haben es mehrfach gehört es gibt viele
Wahlen im Jahr
2024 wir wählen auch die neuen
Institutionen in der Europäischen Union
und auch wenn der innenpolitische Fokus
immer der am stärksten ausgeprägt ist
sollten wir diese Wahl nicht
unterschätzen ich sage auch hier mit
Blick auf Gerhard Mang Gott blicken wir
10 Jahre zurück es war auch unsere
europäische handlungsschwäche im Vorfeld
der damaligen Wahlen zum Europäischen
Parlament die 2014 vielleicht Wladimir
Putin eingeladen haben Aktionen zu
setzen die vielleicht nicht gesetzt
hätte wäre Europa hier auch stärker
aufgetreten sie ist daher auch unsere
Verpflichtung als Mitgliedstaaten hier
dazu beizutragen dass diese Phase der
latenten handlungsschwäche der
Europäischen Union eine möglichst kurze
ist denn die Entwicklungen in der Welt
lassen es nicht zu dass wir zu viel Zeit
verstreichen lassen und hier als Europa
letzten Endes nicht handlungsfähig sind
das bringt mich zu drei konkreten
Ableitungen auch für Österreich auch aus
verteidigungspolitischer Sicht erstens
wir müssen strategiefäh er werden als
Österreich und da geht es mir nicht nur
um ein Dokument das vielleicht
österreichische Sicherheitsstrategie
heißt ich zitiere hier völlig zurecht
die Frau Bundesminister unser Teil ist
schon längst fertig eine Strategie
erzeugt keine Fähigkeiten eine Strategie
ist auch nicht dafür da um letzten Endes
alles entsprechend regeln zu können wir
müssen eine Strategie auch entsprechend
Leben und eine Strategie entsprechend
umsetzen wir müssen so wie auch Erwin
hammeseder angesprochen hat uns die
Frage stellen wo sind unsere
Abhängigkeiten wie können wir diese
Abhängigkeiten reduzieren was ist
notwendig um unser Lebensmodell
entsprechend aufrecht zu erhalten all
das kann nicht in einem singulären
Dokument verankert sein all das bedarf
einer weiteren Befassung der wir uns
alle entsprechend zu stellen haben es
bringt mich zum zweiten das kann ich
ganz kurz machen bin völlig D Kor mit
Günther Hofbauer wir müssen auch unsere
militärischen Hausaufgaben machen und
wir müssen militärisch handlungsfähig
und verteidigungsfähig sein das wird
auch von einem Land wie Österreich im
Herzen Europas letzten Endes erwartet
das führt mich zum dritten und
abschließenden Punkt es ist öfter das
der Begriff der geistigen
Landesverteidigung heute gefallen der
durchschnittliche Österreicher weißer
mit Blick darauf dass er letzten Endes
das eine sehr hohle Phrase ist die
oftmals wenn der Kongress tanzt und wir
befinden ja uns n in mitten der
Ballsaison wir oftmals darauf vergessen
dass es mehr ist als nur ein
Lippenbekenntnis was wir im Bereich der
Sicherheit und Verteidigungspolitik zu
tun haben wir müssen uns intensiv damit
auseinandersetzen vor welchen
Herausforderungen wir stehen wie wir uns
auch bereit sind zu positionieren wofür
wir auch bereit sind letztenendes
einzutreten und das was wir in unserer
Strategie niederschreiben auch
entsprechend umsetzen zu können dafür
dient auch das risikobild um einen
Anstoß zu geben nicht um schlechte Laune
zu verbreiten und ihnen das sonnige
Wetter äh sozusagen etwas benebelter
erscheinen zu lassen sondern darüber
nachzudenken vor welchen
Herausforderungen wir auch als
Gesellschaft stehen und wie wir auch als
Gesellschaft diese Herausforderungen
entsprechend bewältigen können um um zum
Titel der Publikation wieder
zurückzukommen den notwendigen Kit die
notwendige Fugenmasse auch als
Gesellschaft aufzubauen um für die
Ordnung in der Welt zu sorgen daher
lassen Sie mich abschließend die
Gelegenheit ergreifen mich sehr herzlich
bei Ihnen sehr geehrte Frau für die
profunde
Einhalten des Zeit für meinen eigenen
Mitarbeiter weiß es immer schwierig ist
das zu bewerkstelligen ich danke all den
penelisten und Rednerinnen und Rednern
des heutigen Tages so wie den Autorinnen
und Autoren ich danke dir sehrte Frau
Bundesminister dass du uns auch die
Möglichkeit gibst über den Tellerrand im
Rahmen dieser Publikation zu blicken und
vielleicht auch Wahrheiten anzusprechen
die oftmals im politischen Diskurs nicht
ganz so gerne gesehen werden aber ich
glaube das ist auch die Aufgabe von
Verteidigung poliitik letzten Endes
darüber zu reden mein großer Dank gilt
aber auch dir sehr geehte Herr
Generalanwalt lieber Generalmajor
hammeseder dass du uns auch heuer wieder
die Räumlichkeiten zur Verfügung
gestellt hast du hast anfangs erwähnt es
handelt sich bereits eine Tradition ich
sehe aus meiner Sicht keinen Grund mit
Blick auf 2025 diese Tradition zu
brechen in dieser in dieser Hinsicht
danke Ihnen allen auch den
Medienvertretern für das zahlreiche
Erscheinen genießen Sie das Mittagessen
reden sie darüber wie wir diese Welt
wieder in die Fugen bringen können
vielen herzlichen
Dank wir nehmen vieles mit nach Hause
Bescheid wissen und vorbereitet sein
aber auch das risikobild Österreich 2024
und die ersten Exemplare wird die Frau
Bundesministerin signiert an die Speaker
und speakerinnen jetzt verteilen und Sie
bekommen das natürlich auch äh heute und
jetzt dann ausgeteilt sie können es aber
auch downloaden es gibt auf Englisch und
auf Deutsch gibt's das Werk es hat
mehrere hundert Seiten ich habe schon
reingelesen es ist wirklich lesenswert
Verteidigungspolitik at da können sie es
runterladen wir danken für die
Aufmerksamkeit und die Journalisten und
Journalistinnen können gerne jetzt
Interviews auch mit den ExpertInnen
machen vielen Dank und einen schönen
[Applaus]
Tag